WILL GO AND GET STARTED CENTER
GLAZERS ON OKAY.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING TODAY
AND JOINING US ON THE JOINT
OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED PRIVATE COLLEGES WITH
ROUGHLY FIFTY OF THEM IN MY
DISTRICT.
PRIVATE SCHOOL ROMAN --
HAS DECLINED AFTER PEAKING IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN THE MIDST
OF THIS DECLINE WE'VE WITNESSED
A SERIES OF SCHOOL CLOSURES IN
THIS SECTION --
SECTOR EXCUSE ME.
WE KNOW THAT THE SCHOOL SERVE
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS AND
OFFER MORE FLEXIBILITY THAN
TRADITIONAL COLLEGES OR
UNIVERSITIES HOWEVER WE ALSO
KNOW THAT MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENT LOANS THAT
ARE DEFAULTED ON HAVE BORROWED.
AND ATTENDED A FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS TO GAIN AN
UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
ANSWERS ENSURE STUDENTS ENROLL
IN QUALITY EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
THAT LEAD TO MEANINGFUL DEGREES
AND GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
IN ADDITION WE'LL ALSO HEAR FROM
PANELISTS ABOUT EFFORTS UNDERWAY
TO ASSIST STUDENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED BY SCHOOL CLOSURE.
SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL PRIOR
HEARINGS REGARDING CLOSURES
NAMELY THAT OF CORINTHIAN
COLLEGE WHERE WE DISCUSS THE
EDUCATIONAL AND FINANCIAL
REPERCUSSIONS. FOR STUDENTS
IMACTED BY AN ABRUPT INTO THEIR
STUDIES.
THIS IS AN EXPERIENCE MOST
RECENTLY FELL BY STUDENTS AT
BRIGHTWOOD COLLEGE CAMPUSES
WHICH CLOSED ITS DOORS LAST
DECEMBER.
WHAT WE LEARNED AT THAT HEARING
CONTINUES TO BE HE'S HEARING?
OUR ABILITY TO SUPPORT QUALITY
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT IS VITAL TO
STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE'VE ALSO LEARNED THAT THESE
CASES THAT FROM THESE CASES THAT
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO PROTECT
OUR TUDENTS INVESTMENT.
IN COMPLETING THEIR EDUCATION IS
LIMITED.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT WILL SHED
SOME LIGHT ON THESE AREAS TODAY%
BUT THE STATE IN ITS CAPACITY
CAN FACILITATE THE REALIZATION
OF EDUCATIONAL GOALS FOR
STUDENTS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
THAT SAID I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE CENTER STEVE GLAZER
THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE IT'S A
REALLY LONG NAME --
BE A P. I GUESS THAT'S WHY WE
NORMALLY CAUGHT THAT RIGHT --
IS A JOINING CONVENER TODAY AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO MAKE A
FEW REMARKS.
THANK YOU AT YOUR LEYVA THANK
YOU FOR ALL.
FOLKS ARE HERE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS YEAR AND I THINK THE HAIRS --
OPENING REMARKS I SHARE --
THESE.
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL AN INVALUABLE
[inaudible]
AND YOU TO SEE --
A TRAIL OF US SOME BROKEN HEARTS
AND BROKEN WALLETS --
ALONG THE WAY AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT --
WHAT WE DO HERE AND I KNOW WHAT --
THE LEADERS OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS ARE COMMITTED TO IS
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE STUDENTS.
AND HOW WE CAN HELP THEM SUCCEED
IN LIFE AND GIVE THEM THE TOOLS
TO TO BE. TO BE SUCCESSFUL --
YET US SCHOOLS CLOSING AND THE
DEBT THAT STUDENTS HAVE INCURRED
AND WANTED KNOW WHETHER THEY'VE
GOTTEN TO THOSE GOALS THAT WE
SHARE THAT THERE'S SOME QUICK
QUESTIONS THERE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE TESTIMONY TODAY.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE DOING
AND WHAT WE CAN DO BETTER THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
CARE GLAZER.
ALRIGHT WELL WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PRIVATE POST POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION SECTOR.
DEBBIE COCHRAN ARE YOU HERE.
COME ON DOWN.
DEBBIE IS EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND STUDENT
SUCCESS ALSO KNOWN AS TAKE US
YOU CAN SIT WHEREVER YOU FEEL
MOST COMFORTABLE.
WELCOME AGAIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY -- AND
FOR TO PROVIDE A BROAD OVERVIEW
OF HIGHER EDUCATION OVERSIGHT --
AN OUTLINE SOME RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WE SEE AS
READY FOR CONSIDERATION BY YOUR
COMMITTEES.
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS IS A NONPROFIT
NONPARTISAN RESEARCH AND POLICY
ORGANIZATION WITH HEADQUARTERS
IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND
WASHINGTON DC.
I'M TICKETS FOCUSES ON FEDERAL
IN CALIFORNIA STATE POLICY AIMED
AT IMPROVING COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY EQUITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'M SO WHILE THE TOPIC OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS THE BUREAU
FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EUCATION MY MY REMARKS ARE
AIMED AT PROVIDING SOME OF THE
BROADER CONTEXT.
NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND BOTH HOW
THE ROLES AND EXPECTATIONS OF
OTHER OVERSEERS ARE EVOLVING AND
ALSO EMERGING TRENDS --
THAT CALL FOR PARTICULAR
ATTENTION IN CALIFORNIA --
UNDER FEDERAL LAW THERE ARE
THREE ENTITIES THAT SHARE
PRIMARY PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR OVERSEEING HIGHER EDUCATION.
INSTITUTIONS THAT RECEIVE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID.
THE ACCREDITING AGENCIES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND STATE.
ACCREDITING AGENCIES ARE TASKED
WITH CATION QUALITY.
TING AGENCIES ARE MEMBERSHIP
INSTITUTIONS THAT USE PEER
REVIEW TO ASSESS WHETHER
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS ARE HEARING
TO TO FIND AN ESTABLISH
STANDARDS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RELIES
UPON THESE AGENCIES
DETERMINATIONS AB THAT OF
WHETHER OF SCHOOLS ARE OF
SUFFICIENT QUALITY FOR FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS.
REGIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCIES
DEFINE IT.
OUR SERVER DEFINED GEOGRAPHICAL
REGION I'M IN A CREDIT MOSTLY
PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT SCHOOLS
NATIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCIES
TYPICALLY HAVE ORE OF A CAREER
FOCUS.
AND OVERSEE MOSTLY FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES.
HISTORICALLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS FOCUSED ON
COLLEGES FISCAL STABILITY IN
COMPLIANCE WITH PROGRAMMATIC
RULES OF FEDERAL AID PROGRAMS.
I'M IN FORCES MINIMUM STANDARDS
SET BY CONGRESS SUCH AS THE RULE
THAT NO MORE THAN 30% OF A
SCHOOL'S FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN
DEFAULTERS VOTERS IN THE
BORROWERS CAN FAULT IN THEIR ON
THEIR STUDENT LOANS --
AND ALSO THAT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES RECEIVE NO MORE THAN
90% OF THEIR AID FROM I HAVE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID REVENUE
FROM FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID.
I'M IT ADDITIONALLY SET SOME OF
THE STANDARDS OF ITS OWN SUCH AS
IMPLEMENTING THE REQUIREMENT
THAT CAREER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
LEAVE THEIR GRADUATES WITH
MANAGEABLE DEATH.
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO PROVIDES
STUDENT LOAN JUST CHARGERS TO
STUDENTS USE QUIPPER SCHOOL
CLOTHES OR DEFRAUD THEM.
YES STATE APPROVE ALL
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS OPERATE
WITHIN THEIR BORDERS AND
ESTABLISH PROCESSES FOR HOW THEY
WILL OVERSEE THESE COLLEGES.
THEY ALSO ESTABLISH CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR THE RESIDENTS
WHO ARE ENROLLED IN COLLEGES.
NOW THESE RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
RECOGNIZED AND AN AIDE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE ARE
LEGALLY AUTHORIZED TO OPERATE IN
THE STATE AND THAT THE STATE HAS
A PROCESS. FOR ACCEPTING AN
ACTING UPON COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
SCHOOL WHEN THE CALIFORNIA THE
PRIMARY ENTITY TASKED WITH THIS
IS THE BPP THE PAIR OF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
I'M FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATION
PROVIDE PARAMETERS OF EXPECTED
LEVELS OF OVERSIGHT FOR EACH OF
THESE ENTITIES WITH WIDELY
VARYING LEVELS OF GRANULARITY.
AS A FOR INSTANCE FEDERAL LAW
RECOGNIZES STATES BROAD
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
INSTITUTIONS AS THEY SEE FIT.
WHERE'S CONGRESS IN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAVE
DEFINED VERY CLEAR TERMS AND
STANDARDS FOR BOTH FEDERAL
OVERSIGHT AND THAT OF
ACCREDITING AGENCIES.
HOWEVER THESE ROLES MAYBE
EVOLVING IN WAYS THAT ARE
CRITICAL FOR STATES TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
CURRENTLY MIDSTREAM IN A WIDE
REACHING DE REGULATORY EFFORT
THAT WOULD WEAKEN OVERSIGHT BY
BOTH THE CREDITORS AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR INSTANCE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
CHANGES THAT WOULD EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATE DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN
REGIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCIES
AND NATIONAL ACCREDITING
AGENCIES.
IT THIS DISTINCTION IS RELIED
UPON IN CALIFORNIA LAW TO BOTH
TARGET OVERSIGHT AND FINES.
SCHOOLS ACCREDITED BY THE
REGIONAL ACCREDITOR SERVING OF
CALIFORNIA THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES ARE WHY ASK.
ARE EXEMPT FROM BBB OVERSIGHT
UNDER STATE LAW.
IT IS ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE STATE
CAL GRANTS THE SIZE OF THE CAL
GRANT THEY CAN RECEIVE --
CAN DEPEND ON WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE ACCREDITED BY WHY ASK
FOR THESE PROVISIONS WOULD MAKE
LITTLE SENSE OF THOSE
DISTINCTIONS WERE RAISED AND
FEDERAL LAW.
I'M IN ANOTHER PROPOSED CHANGE
CHANGE OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CURRENT RULES
ALLOW ACCREDITED COLLEGES TO
OUTSOURCE UP TO HALF OF AN
ACADEMIC PROGRAM TO OUTSIDE
ENTITIES WHICH THEMSELVES ARE
UNACCREDITED --
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
TO RAISE THAT HALFLIMIT THAT
50% LIMIT 275% PROVIDING
TAXPAYER SUBSIDY TO PROGRAMS
OFFERED PRIMARILY BY
UNACCREDITED PROVIDERS.
EARLIER IN ITS NEGOTIATIONS THAT
MINISTRATION PROPOSED TO
ELIMINATE THAT LIMIT ENTIRELY.
ALSO UNDER CURRENT FEDERAL RULES
ACCREDITING AGENCIES THEMSELVES
MUST COMPLY WITH A SLATE OF
CRITERIA TO DEMONSTRATE THEIR
ABILITY TO HOLD COLLEGES
ACCOUNTABLE.
AN AGENCY THAT DON'T MEET THOSE
CRITERIA CAN LOSE FEDERAL
RECOGNITION MEANING THAT THE
AGENCIES ACCREDITATION NO LONGER
ABLE TO SCHOOL TO GET FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID --
WELL ACCREDITING AGENCIES LOSING
RECOGNITION AND IN THIS WAY IS
INCREDIBLY RARE IT DIDN'T REACH
OCCUR RECENTLY IT OCCURRED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ENDED RECOGNITION
OF THE ACCREDITING COUNCIL FOR
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND SCHOOLS
OR KNOWN AS A CICS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT A CICS WAS
STILL NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
REQUIRED STANDARDS.
NOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
LOOKING TO CHANGE FEDERAL RULES
AROUND ACCREDITATION.
SO TO ALLOW RECOGNITION OF
ACCREDITING AGENCIES THAT MERELY
SHOW SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE WITH
THE STANDARDS NOT FULL
COMPLIANCE AND IT'S FURTHER
WEAKENING THE MEANING
ACCREDITATION.
I'M THIS IS IN ADDITION TO YOU --
OTHER CHANGESTHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS ALREADY
PROPOSED INCLUDING ELIMINATING
THE FEDERAL GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
RULE THAT ENFORCES THE HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT'S REQUIREMENT.
THAT CAREER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT AND RECOGNIZED
OCCUPATION.
ON THE ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
PROPOSED A SCALE BACK RULES
PROVIDING STUDENT LOAN JUST
CHARGES TO STUDENTS IN
CONNECTION WITH FRAUD OR OTHER
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES OF THEIR
SCHOOLS --
STATE LEVEL ACCOUNTING OF THE
NUMBER OF THE STUDENTS WHO OF
COURSE FILED CLAIMS FOR BORROWER
DEFENSE DISCHARGES SHOW THAT ONE
IN FIVE CLAIMANTS ARE CAP FROM
CALIFORNIA.
SO NONE OF THESE RULES WILL GO
INTO EFFECT UNTIL JULY TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE EARLIEST AND SOME
OF THEM MAY BE CHALLENGED IN
COURT EXTENDING THEM EVEN
FURTHER.
BUT THEY NONE THE LESS REPRESENT
OF FAR REACHING THE REGULATORY
AGENDA THAT WOULD SCALE BACK
STUDENT TAXPAYER PROTECTIONS AND
OPEN NEW AVENUES FOR ABUSE.
THE CNGRESS IS ALSO POISED TO
RE AUTHORIZE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT --
GOVERNING FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS AND DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS HAVE WITH WIDELY
DIVERGENT VIEWS ON WHAT CHANGES
NEED TO BE MADE TO A PROPERLY
HOLD COLLEGES ACCOUNTABLE.
AS A RESULT OF ALL OF THIS
ACTIVITY IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
FOR STATES TO THINK ABOUT THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION ROLLED MORE
BROADLY THAN THEY HAVE IN THE
PAST. TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
RESIDENTS OF THE LEVEL OF
PROTECTION THAT THEY DEEM
APPROPRIATE REGARDLESS OF HOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROCEEDS.
SO I WOULD LIKE NOW TO DISCUSS
WITH YOU THREE IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE LANDSCAPE AND HOW THEY
RELATE TO CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST --
IS THE ISSUE OF SCHOOLS THAT
CLOSE UNEXPECTEDLY AND BEFORE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO FINISH
THEIR PROGRAMS.
SINCE THE TWENTY FIFTEEN CLOSURE
OF CORINTHIAN COLLEGES WHICH
PRIMARILY AFFECTED CALIFORNIANS
SEVERAL OTHER FOR PROFIT COLLEGE
CHAIN SOME CLOSE THEIR DOORS.
WESTWOOD COLLEGE ENROLLED
PRIMARY PRIMARILY CALIFORNIANS
BEFORE IT CLOSED.
OF THE FIFTY SIX CAMPUSES OF
MARINELLA SCHOOLS OF BEAUTY THAT
BECAUSE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THIRTY
NINE OF THEM THIRTY NINE OF THE
FIFTY SIX WERE IN CALIFORNIA.
OTHER CLOSURES INCLUDING ITT
TECHNICAL INSTITUTES AND SCHOOLS
OWN BY THE EDUCATION CORPORATION
OF AMERICA INCLUDING BRIGHT WHAT
COLLEGE.
I HAVEN'T ALSO INCLUDED LARGE
NUMBERS OF CALIFORNIANS.
NO SCHOOL CLOSURES CAN LEAVE
STUDENTS UNABLE TO FINISH THE
PROGRAMS FOR WHICH THEY BORROWED
TO ATTEND CAN BE DISASTROUS FOR
STUDENTS.
SCHOOL THAT CLOSE TEND TO BE
ONES WITH RELATIVELY POOR
REPUTATIONS AND EVEN STUDENTS
WHO ARE ABLE TO TRANSFER THEIR
COURSE WORK TO COMPLETE THEIR
PROGRAM MAY NOT BE WELL SERVED.
AND REPUTABLE SCHOOLS MAY NOT
ACCEPT THE COURSEWORK TAKEN AT
THE CLOSE SCHOOL.
AND WHILE THOSE THAT ACCEPT THE
COURSEWORK READILY ARE OFTEN
THOSE WITH LOWER ACADEMIC
STANDARDS.
AS A CASE IN POINT EDUCATION
CORPORATION --
THAT WAS ANNOUNCED IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFFECTED
CALIFORNIANS IT ROLLED CROSS
TEN CAMPUSES OF RIGHT WOULD
COLLEGE PLUS THE GOLF ACADEMY OF
AMERICA.
THE ONLY CALIFORNIA BASED
TRANSFER OPTIONS ECA ARE
PROMOTING OUR AT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES. FOR STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS WHO DO NOT TRANSFER
COURSE WORK TO COMPLETE THEIR
PRIOR PROGRAM.
FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS STUDENTS
AFFECTED BY A SCHOOL CLOSURE TO
HAVE THEIR STUDENT LOANS
DISCHARGED.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ALSO
BEGAN RESTORING STUDENTS
ELIGIBILITY FOR PELL GRANTS.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ALMOST TWO
DOZEN STATES WITH THE STATE
TUITION RECOVERY FUND KNOWN AS
STRESS -- TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL OR
ALTERNATIVE SOURCE OF FINANCIAL
RELIEF THAT CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM
IS MORE GENEROUS THAN FEDERAL
RELIEF IN A FEW WAYS.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS USE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS CLOSE NOT
JUST OUR SCHOOLS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR RELIEF UNDER STRESS.
EVEN IF THE SCHOOL ITSELF
REMAINS OPEN --
STRESS CAN HELP STUDENTS TO HAVE
PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN DEBT IN
ADDITION TO JUST FEDERAL STUDENT
OANS I CAN EVEN HELP REIMBURSE
THIRD PARTIES THAT HAVE PAID FOR
TUITION WITHOUT LOANS.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA'S STRYFE ONLY
REIMBURSES COSTS THAT WERE
INCURRED TO PAY FOR TUITION AND
NOT ANY OF THE OTHER DIRECT
COSTS AT THE INSTITUTE ANY OTHER
DIRECT COSTS OF COLLEGE.
IN THIS WAY THE STATE'S RIFF
PROGRAM IS MORE STRINGENT THAN
FEDERAL DISCHARGES.
I'M CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS ARE
CURRENTLY EX RECOGNIZE THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE IN THE STATE
WE WANT TO APPLY SOME OF THOSE
LESSONS TO THIS REFER GRAHAM AS
WELL.
SECONDLY --
THE WAYS IN WHICH COLLEGES USE
MISLEADING AND DECEPTIVE
INFORMATION TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL HAS RECEIVE
SUBSTANTIAL ATTENTION AND
FEDERAL POLICY.
FEDERAL LAW ENTITLES STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS WHO ARE
MISTREATED OR LIE TO BUY THEIR
COLLEGE TO GET THERE FEDERAL
LOANS DISCHARGED.
THIS PROVISION WAS RARELY USED
UNTIL THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION --
WHEN IN COLLABORATION WITH THEN
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
KAMALA HARRIS DOCUMENTED
WIDESPREAD MISREPRESENTATIONS
WITH CORINTHIAN COLLEGE --
WITH CAMPUSES KNOWN AS EVEREST
HE'LL THEN WHY ATTACK AND THAT
JOINT INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT
THE COMPANY HAD INFLATED
GRADUATES LIKELIHOOD OF FINDING
EMPLOYMENT ACROSS HUNDREDS OF
PROGRAMS OFFERED. FOR EXAMPLE
THE LOS ANGELES CAMPUS OF WHY
ATTACK ADVERTISE A JOB PLACEMENT
RATE OF 80%. FOR ITS AUOMOTIVE
TECHNICIAN CERTIFICATE PROGRAM
BUT THE RECALCULATED JOB
PLACEMENT RATE WAS JUST SIT 26%.
THE ONTARIO CAMPUS OF EVEREST
COLLEGE REPORTED THAT 78% OF
MEDICAL ASSISTING CERTIFICATE
GRADUATES LANDED JOBS WHERE THE
RECALCULATED RATE WAS JUST 52%.
WITH OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS AFFECTED BY
MISREPRESENTATIONS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PROMULGATED NEW
RULES AND PROCESS SEES THAT
PROVIDE AN EXPEDITED PATH
TOWARDS RELIEF FOR STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN HARMED --
THIS INCLUDES STUDENTS FROM MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
BASED PROGRAM.
I HAD MORE RELIABLE VERIFIABLE
DATA ON EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES BEEN
AVAILABLE TO OVERSEERS AT THE
TIME THAT STUDENTS WERE BEING
MISLED THE STATE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO IDENTIFY SOME OF THESE
FALSEHOODS EARLIER.
SOME BUT NOT ALL RECRUITING
AGENCIES REQUIRE STUDENTS TO
REPLACE REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO
REPORT ON GRADUATES EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES.
THE CALIFORNIA DOES FOR AB
REQUIRE BPP COVERED INSTITUTIONS
TO REPORT.
ON STUDENTS POST COMPLETION
OUTCOMES EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES BUT
THE DATA IS COLLECTED BY THE
INSTITUTIONS THROUGH ALUMNI
SURVEYS AND IS TOO INFREQUENTLY
VERIFIED BY STATE THE STATE OR
ANY THIRD PARTY ACTOR.
THE STATE'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT OR AGES
THROUGH THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM AND THAT DATE
IS ALREADY BEING USED BY THE
PUBLIC COLLEGES THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M SO YET WHILE THE STRIDES
HAVE BEEN MADE TO YOU TO BETTER
CONNECT PUBLIC COLLEGE STUDENT
RECORDS TO WAGE DATA AND TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES.
NOTHING OTHER THAN SCHOOL
REPORTED DATA EXISTS FOR PRIVATE
COLLEGES.
THE CALIFORNIA COULD HELP TO
PROVIDE A CONSISTENT LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS ALL SCHOOLS.
BY REQUIRING COLLEGES AND
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROVIDERS TO
REPORT STUDENT LEVEL INFORMATION
O THE BUREAU.
AND FACILITATING THE CUP
CONNECTION OF THAT DATA THE WAGE
DATA IN ORDER TO ASSESS POST
COLLEGE PERFORMANCE.
DOING SO WOULD MAKE IT EASIER
FOR POLICYMAKERS STUDENTS AND
INSTITUTIONS TO ASSESS POST
COMPLETION OUTCOMES AND WOULD
HELP IDENTIFY INSTANCES OF FRAUD
BEFORE THEIR WIDESPREAD.
FINALLY I WANT TO DISCUSS ONLINE
EDUCATION.
SOME POLICY MAKERS HOPE THAT
ONLINE EDUCATION CAN BE THAN
HELP MANY MORE STUDENTS EARN
COLLEGE DEGREES THROUGH HIS JET
GEOGRAPHIC REACH.
FLEXIBLE SCHEDULING AND
POTENTIAL TO SCALE.
HOWEVER THE CHALLENGES IN THE SS
IN ACADEMIC RIGOR AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES CAN BE EVEN GREATER AN
ONLINE EDUCATION THAN IN
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
AND THERE'S A LONG HISTORY OF
OVER PRICED AND POOR QUALITY
PROGRAMS LEAVING STUDENTS WITH
THAT THAT'LL STRUGGLE TO REPAY.
THE GROWTH OF ONLINE EDUCATION
CAN COMPLICATE STATE OVERSIGHT.
YOUR STATES CANNON TO REGULATE
COMMERCE THAT'S CONDUCTED BY
COMPANIES HEADQUARTERED OUT OF
STATE.
HIGHER EDUCATION OVERSIGHT IS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON
SCHOOLS LOCATED INSIDE THE STATE
NOT THOSE OFFERING EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS ACROSS STATE LINES.
MOST CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED IN
ONLINE CATCH EDUCATION ARE AT
CALIFORNIA BASED SCHOOLS --
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN PARTICULAR.
BUT ABOUT ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE EDUCATION
PROVIDE PROGRAMS OFFERED BY
SCHOOLS AND OTHER STATES.
MORE THAN 40% OF THESE STUDENTS
ARE ENROLLED IN FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES OR AT NONPROFIT
COLLEGES OF QUESTIONABLE
LEGITIMACY.
THERE'S REASON TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE STUDENTS.
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS THAT
AND ROLL CALIFORNIANS ONLINE
HAVE WORSE STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT OUTCOMES AND
CALIFORNIA BASED DISTANCE
EDUCATION PROVIDERS. THREE YEARS
AFTER COLLEGE 30% OF BORROWERS
FROM OUT OF STATE SCHOOLS AND
ROLLING CALIFORNIANS ON MINOR
PAIN DOWN THEIR DEBT COMPARED
2405% OF STUDENT LOANS --
DO NUMBERS FROM CALIFORNIA
DISTANCED --
AND PROVIDERS.
THE SHARE OF BORROWERS TO END UP
IN THE FALL IS ALSO HIRE AN OUT
OF STATE DISTANCE EDUCATION
PROVIDERS THAN IN STATE
PROVIDERS.
IMPORTANTLY CALIFORNIA CANNON
ACTS NEW PROTECTIONS FOR
STUDENTS --
IN ROLLED OUT OF STATE BECAUSE
IT HAS NOT JOINED THE INTERSTATE
RECIPROCITY AGREEMENT THAT OTHER
STATES HAVE.
THIS AGREEMENT DEVELOPED AND
MANAGED BY THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
FOR STATE AUTHORIZATION
RECIPROCITY AGREEMENTS COMMONLY
KNOWN AS SARAH.
IS DESIGNED TO STREAMLINE THE
ABILITY OF SCHOOLS WITHIN THEIR
OWN BORDERS TO ENROLL STUDENTS
BASED ELSEWHERE.
HOWEVER IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
STREAMLINED PROCESS.
AT PARTICIPATING STATES MUST
GIVE UP THEIR AUTHORITY TO APPLY
NEW OR EXISTING HIGHER EDUCATION
LAWS TO SCHOOLS AND ROLE IN THE
RESIDENCE.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT JOINED SERRA
AND THAT'S RETAINS ITS ABILIY
TO REGULATE OUT OF STATE SCHOOLS
AND ROLLING CALIFORNIANS.
HOWEVER IT'S DONE LITTLE WITH
THIS AUTHORITY TO DATE.
I'M OUT OF STATE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES MUST REGISTER WITH THE
BUREAU AND PAY INTO THE STATE'S
STRESS FOR EACH CALIFORNIAN
ENROLLED.
BUT NO OTHER CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION LAW APPLIES TO THESE
SCHOOLS.
AS A LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS HOW
BEST TO STRENGTHEN OVERSIGHT IT
SHOULD CONSIDER WHAT ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS ARE NEEDED TO PROTECT
THE TATE'S RESIDENTS
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER INVOLVES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SHARE THESE THOUGHTS.
WELCOME TO QUESTIONS VERY MUCH
MISS COCHRAN THAT WAS VERY HOLE
ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
OKAY.
SURE CLOSER DID YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
I DO -- SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
IT'S IT'S AN INFORMATIVE AND
IT'S ALSO --
TROUBLING --
I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
OTHERS ABOUT --
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SHOULDN'T AT
SHOULD BE DOING.
BUT I I I GUESS I'D LIKE TO BE
PROVOCATIVE AT THE BEGINNING
HERE --
YOU'VE MADE A NUMBER OF
SUGGESTIONS OF OF WHERE YOU
THINK WE COULD BE DOING BETTER.
WOULD YOU TALK TO ME FOR A
MOMENT ABOUT OUR CURRENT BUREAU
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE THAT THE
END IS INVOLVED IN THESE AREAS --
WE ARE THEY INVOLVED ARE THEY
NOT WHAT'S YOUR INVOLVEMENT WITH
THEM OR OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING WE'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM THEM IN A FEW
MINUTES BUT I THINK WE BENEFIT
FROM HERE.
YOUR EXAMINATION ON OUR BEHALF
AS TO WHERE THEY'RE GOING RIGHT
AND WRONG.
YEAH THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION I FEEL LIKE IT I'M NOT
AS FAMILIAR CERTAINLY AS YOUR
FLAWS A SUBSEQUENT PANELS WILL
BE IN TERMS OF THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE BUREAU I THINK.
IMPORTANT STRIDES HAVE BEEN MADE
IN RECENT YEARS --
IMPORTANTLY THE CREATION OF THAT
OF SORRY THE OFFICE OF STUDENT
ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF --
I KNOW THEY'VE BEEN A VERY
ACTIVE WITH SOME DEVELOPMENTS OF
LATE -- I
THINK WHAT IS ALSO IMPORTANT AS
YOU THINK ABOUT HOW WELL THEY'RE
IMPLEMENTING THAT LAWS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON THE BOOKS IS THE
THINK ABOUT WHAT NEW AUTHORITY
EITHER THEY OR OTHER ENTITIES
WILL NEED TO PROVIDE BACKSTOPS
TO SOME OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
FEDERALLY.
ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY INITIATIVES
THAT THEIR ADVANCE SOME OF THEM
ARE PRETTY. FOR YOU WHERE
THEY'VE BEEN PROBLEMS FOR A LONG
TIME ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY
INITIATIVES THEY'VE BEEN
ADVANCING --
I AM NOT OKAY.
I GUESS THAT WOULD GIVE THEM
SOME TIME TO THINK ABOUT THAT
QUESTION WHERE THEY GET UP HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WEAKENING THE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS?
WILL THIS THEN MAKE IT HARDER
FOR STUDENTS WHO GRADUATE FROM
THE SCHOOLS HARDER FOR THEM TO
FIND A JOB BECAUSE WE DEAL IF
THEY'RE NOT ACCREDITED WE CAN.
EXTRAPOLATE OUT THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDING THE BEST EDUCATION
POSSIBLE.
I MEAN DO YOU THINK THAT'S TRUE.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IS WE'LL MAKE IT EASIER
FOR COLLEGES TO BECOME
ACCREDITED --
SAID THIS BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT IT DOES NOT MEAN AS I'D
LIKE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
ACCREDITED ACCREDITATION STANDS
FOR QUALITY IS WHAT WILL CHANGE
AND THAT IN TURN OF COURSE WILL
MAKE IT HARDER.
FOR STUDENTS GET THE EDUCATION
THEY NEED AND THEN FIND AND HOLD
JOBS.
THANK YOU THAT WAS MY POINT I
WAS TRYING TO MAKE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE CLOSED --
QUITE A FEW IN THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS IS THERE A COMMON THEME
ARE COMMON DENOMINATOR AND WHY
THE SCHOOLS CLOSED IS IT
FINANCIAL IS IT --
ARE THEY NOT BEING RUN PROP --
I THINK IT WILL I THINK YOU
WOULD PROBABLY FIND SOME OF BOTH
OF THOSE THINGS --
YOU KNOW THAT THEY WERE NOT BE
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE --
AND THAT THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
SCHOOLS WERE NOT DOING WHAT THEY
NEED IT.
OKAY.
AND THEN WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE DECEPTIVE WAYS.
AND WHERE DO THEY GET THEIR
NUMBERS IF THE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
PLACE WAS SAYING THAT THE PLACE
80% OF THEIR GRADUATES BUT THEN
WHEN SOMEONE CAME IN AND REALLY
CALCULATED THAT NUMBER IS ONLY
26%.
ARE THE ARE THE SCHOOLS ARE WE
ARE WE LED TO BELIEVE THAT THE
SCHOOLS ARE JUST MAKING THESE
NUMBERS UP.
I'M WITHOUT SPEAKING TO THAT
PARTICULAR EXAMPLE BECAUSE NOT
SURE ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
DIFFERENCE --
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF WAYS THAT
SCHOOLS CAN BE --
YOU KNOW.
USE RECORDS I'M IN A WAY THAT
DOES NOT REPRESENT AN ACTUAL JOB
PLACEMENT --
COUNTING SOMEONE WHO WAS --
EMPLOYED FOR A SINGLE DAY AND
THE JOB FOR INSTANCE HAS
EMPLOYED OR EVEN IN A VOLUNTEER
POSITION AS EMPLOYED --
SOMETHING THAT ON PAPER MIGHT BE
DOES NOT REPRESENT EMPLOYMENT IN
ANY MEANINGFUL SENSE OF THE WORD
GOTCHA SO MAYBE THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD WORK ON
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT MY LAST QUESTION IS WHAT
EXPECTATIONS --
SHOULD SIT A CALIFORNIA HAVE IN
EXCHANGE FOR GRANTING PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS THE
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE.
SHOULD WE EXPECT FROM THEM.
NO I THINK THE EXPECTATION
SHOULD BE AT ME A BROADLY
SPEAKING THAT YOU'RE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIANS
BETTER OFF AFTER THE AND ROLE
THAN EFORE --
YOU MENTIONED --
CENTER LEYVA THAT THAT MORE THAN
HALF OF STUDENT LOAN DEFAULTERS
I'M IN CALIFORNIA HAVE ATTENDED
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES AND STUDENT
LOAN DEFAULT IS ONLY ONE FORM OF
BORROWER DISTRESS FOR STUDENTS
TO TAKE OUT LOANS TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
BUT IT'S ONE THAT IS A VERY
CLEAR SIGN THAT STUDENTS ARE
BEING LEFT WORSE OFF AFTER
ENROLLMENT THEM BEFORE.
OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YES UNDER DRAWS SO.
AND THEN TALK TO HIM.
WITH FIRM WITH ALL OF THIS BUT
YOU HAVE HERE.
AFFECTED LEGAL --
THE THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
FEDERAL MINISTRATION COULD
EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATE
DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN REGIONAL
ACCREDITING AGENCIES AND
NATIONAL ACCREDITING.
AGENCIES I'M SORRY COULD YOU
EXPLAIN WHAT WHAT THAT MEANS
SURE -- SO
REGIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCIES --
OPERATE WITHIN A DEFINED
GEOGRAPHIC REGION --
ANNA CREDIT MOSTLY PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT SCHOOLS WHERE IS
NATIONAL AGENCIES ARE GENERALLY
CAREER FOCUSED IN AND A CREDIT
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES.
WHAT -- ONE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS AROUND ACCREDITING
AGENCIES WOULD --
MAKE IT HARD IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ACCREDITING AGENCIES TO
LIMIT THEIR GEOGRAPHIC REGION
THAT THEY SERVE IF THEY CAN'T
LIMIT THEIR J. GEOGRAPHIC REGION
THEN THEY WOULD BASICALLY HAVE
TO BECOME NATIONAL --
AND WHAT WE WOULD SEE THEN AS
WITH ALL AGENCIES BI NATIONAL IT
WOULD LEAD TO A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM IN TERMS OF EDUCATIONAL
QUALITY.
BECAUSE OF COURSE THE
ACCREDITING AGENCIES ARE MEMBERS
OFFENSIVE MORE MEMBERS.
WITH WITH THE THAT MEANS.
A STATEWIDE AS WELL.
I'M AND THEY WOULD THEY WERE THE
THE PROPOSAL WOULD LIMIT THE
AGENCY'S ABILITY TO PUT
GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDS ON IN THE
SCHOOLS THEY SIR.
THE CENTER DRAWS A CENTER PM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT IS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE IS --
ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE STATUS.
OR THE HEALTH OF OUR TRADING
PROCESS SO YOU KNOW FULL
DISCLOSURE I ACTUALLY SERVED ON
THE BOARD OF AN ACCREDITING BODY --
IN THE MEDICAL FIELD WHERE WHERE
THERE ARE ACTORS ACTUALLY ONLY
ONE GRADING BODY --
FOR UNDERGRADUATE ALLOPATHIC
MEDICAL EDUCATION THERE'S ONE
FOR RESIDENCY EDUCATION SO IN
THAT CASE THERE'S ONE BODY
EVERYONE LOOKS TOO BUTWHAT IS
GOING ON IN TERMS OF THESE GOALS
IN TERMS OF ACCREDITATION I MEAN
THEY'RE JUST LIKE.
THAT THAT YOU GET TO PICK AND
CHOOSE WHICH ONE YOU WANT OUR
HOUSE IS THERE SOME --
STANDARD DEBTS RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE MOST
IMPORTANT AS A WHAT IS THE
CURRENT STATUS OF A TRADING
BODIES AT THIS AT A FREE FOR ALL
WHERE ANYONE JUST FIX THE
GRADING BODY THEY WANT OR IS
THERE ACTUALLY SOME SORT OF A
RECOGNITION IN THE HIGHER.
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THAT THESE
ARE THERE'S A THERE ARE SPECIFIC
ACCREDITING BODIES THAT ACTUALLY.
ARE.
CREDIBLE AND DO DO DO A GOOD JOB
AND THAT --
AND AND THAT AND TO WHAT DEGREE
IS SOMEONE SAID WHY SO I START
M OWN ACCREDITING BODY RIGHT
AND AND HOW HOW HOW DOES THAT
WORK -- YEAH
I MEAN MOST OF READY AGENCIES
OUR REGION THERE EITHER EITHER
REGIONALLY FOCUSED ARE FOCUSED
OFTEN ON A TOP ON A SET OF YOU
KNOW TYPES OF CAREERS --
YOU KNOW A PARTICULAR SET OF
TRADES FOR INSTANCE --
REGIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCY YOU --
HAVE HIGHER STANDARDS AND HIGHER
LEVELS OF QUALITY --
OFTEN SCHOOLS REGIONALLY
ACCREDITED SCHOOLS WILL HAVE AN
TRANSFER YOUR CREDITS FOR
INSTANCE OF OUR OTHER REGIONALLY
ACCREDITED SCHOOL THEN AND MUCH
LESS SO.
FROM --
NATIONAL NATIONAL ACCREDITING
AGENCIES --
THAT YOUR MIND WITH OTHERS
QUESTION ANY GET OUT IS IS THAT --
YEAH YOU.
TO AND I'VE COLLEGES I MISSED
YOUR VERBAL TEST MAY BY SEE HERE
IS THAT YOU TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
REGIONAL ACCREDITATION BODIES
MOVING TO NATIONAL YOU MADE SOME
REFERENCE IN YOUR ANSWER TO
SENATOR ALSO.
I GUESS IN TERMS OF THE CURRENT
HEALTH OF ACCREDITING IN HIGHER
EDUCATION RIGHT NOW.
IS IT DO WE HAVE A SITUATED SO
FOR EXAMPLE.
IF I WANT TO START MY OWN
ACCREDITATION AGENCY CAN I JUST
GO AND OPEN ONE AND SAY AND AS
LONG AS I'M IN SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE --
THEN WE'RE GOOD AND THAT'S IT WE
HAVE ANYTHING PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE HAVE COLLEGES THAT MAY
NOT DISPLAY PERFORM UP TO
STANDARD BUT WHAT THE STANDARD
SETTERS THEMSELVES OF THEIR SUMS
CONSENSUS THAT.
WE THINK ARE CURRENT VALIDATION
SYSTEM IS ROBUST OR NOT IS IT WE
WE WE TALK ABOUT RACE TO THE
BOTTOM.
IS IS IT IT WHAT WHAT'S THE
LIMITATIONS ON SOMEONE STARTING
THEIR OWN ACCREDITATION AGENCY
THAT THAT THEN ALLOWS YOU KNOW
SUB STANDARD COLLEGES TO BE ABLE
TO EXISTENCE STILL BE QUITE A
QUITE A CREDIT THAT'S THAT'S I
GUESS AND HE DID WHAT IS.
HOW HOW SOUNDS ARE CURRENT
ACCREDITATION SYSTEM IN HIGHER
EDUCATION MENTION TWO EXEMPTIONS
TO A TWO WAYS IN WHICH --
WASCO ACCREDITATION IN
PARTICULAR WAS USED IN
CALIFORNIA STATE OVERSIGHT AND
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM I THINK
THAT'S A REAL THAT'S A
RECOGNITION --
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS IN THE
PAST LOOKED AT WATCHED
ACCREDITATION AS AS MEANING
SOMETHING OF HIGH QUALITY AM AND
IT IS ONE OF THE ACCORDING
AGENCIES THAT HAS SHOWN ITSELF
WILLING TO BE --
TO SCRUTINIZE I'M COLLEGES AND
CHANGES IN COLLEGES --
ME MORE DEEPLY THAN OTHERS --
BUT IT WILL IT WOULD WAKE Và AT
VARIES WIDELY --
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY SOME OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS. TO
ALLOW AND CREDIT AGENCIES THAT
ARE NOT FULLY IN COMPLIANCE WITH
REQUIRED STANDARDS TO CONTINUE
TO BE ACCREDITING AGENCIES I'M
BECAUSE IT WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS -- THIS
RACE TO THE BOTTOM.
YES PLEASE. THREE IS.
IS ACCREDITING HIGHER EDUCATION
AND CALIFORNIA CAN BE AFFECTED
BY THIS AND WE EXPECT TO SEE.
A DETERMINATION OF THE QUALITY
OF HIGHER EDUCATION PARTICULARLY
NOW BECAUSE OF LOWER ACCREDITING
STANDARDS HERE IN STATE --
RIGHT AT THIS MOMENT WHAT WE
HAVE OUR PROPOSALS --
PROPOSES THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED --
WITH A SLATE OF STAKEHOLDERS IN
WASHINGTON DC --
SO THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE
BASICALLY DISCUSSION FOR FINAL
RULES WELL --
LOOK LIKE IS UNCLEAR BUT I WOULD
SAY ULTIMATELY YES THERE ARE
REASONS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE CONCERNED I I
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
THE AC ICS SITUATION ON THAT
THIS WAS AN ACCREDITING AGENCY
THAT WAS OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL STANDARDS --
AND THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ENDED RECOGNITION OF IT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS AS RE
RECOGNIZE THAT REVERSING THE
OBAMA ERA DECISION I'M AND THERE
WERE YOU KNOW DOZENS OF SCHOOLS
THAT WERE BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT WERE ACCREDITED BY A CICS
AND THAT WERE UNABLE TO EVEN
FIND A NEW QUIRK ACCREDITING
AGENCY THIS REALLY DEMONSTRATES --
HOW THAT ACCORDING AGENCY
STANDARDS CAN CREATE A RACE TO
THE BOTTOM AND HOW CALIFORNIANS
ARE AFFECTED?
THE CENTER PAN SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY CONCERN
OF COURSE TO THE VICTIMS THE
VICTIMS ALL THE SHIFTING AN
ACCREDITATION OF BACK AND FORTH
THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
AND THE MAN AT THE UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS THAT ARE WHO RELY IN
THE PALE PROGRAM THE PELL GRANTS
AND HOW DOES ALL THIS --
AFFECT THEM AND ARE THEY TAKEN
OFF THE LIST PUT BACK ON THERE
AGAIN SEEKING THE PELL GRANT
THEY'RE GOING BACK AND INTO THE
PROCESS AGAIN BECAUSE I SEE THIS
IS IS THEY ARE THE VICTIMS.
OF HOW ARE WE PROTECTING THEM.
IN THE CASE OF A CLOSE SCHOOL IN
PARTICULAR OR LIGHT.
I'M.
WHEN THE CASE OF A CLOSE SCHOOL
ACTUALLY IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DID
INSTITUTE SOME CHANGES THAT
WOULD RESTORE PELL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY STUDENTS TO SCHOOL
THAT CLOSE BEFORE THEY WERE
UNABLE -- TO
BEFORE AND THEY WERE UNABLE TO
COMPLETE THE SAME PROVISION DOES
NOT EXIST FOR THE STATE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
CENTER ARCHULETA MEMBERS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT IS COCHRAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP WE WILL HEAR
ABOUT STUDENT COMPLAINTS AND
BUREAU ENFORCEMENT.
OF MICHAEL MERION IF YOU WERE
HERE PLEASE COME ON UP.
AND DEAN --
FILL.
DEAN I FEEL LIKE I WAS HERE LAST
NAME WRONG [inaudible]
WELCOME GENTLEMEN [inaudible]
HELLO.
WE'RE GOOD TO GO THANK YOU.
LISTENERS THANK YOU. FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COME IN TODAY MY
NAME IS DOCTOR MICHAEL MERION
I'M THE BUREAU CHIEF FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION --
FIRST I THINK IS IMPORTANT IN
ORDER FOR YOU TO UNDERSTAND ON
THE BUREAU SHOULD BE IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO FIRST UNDERSTAND ME.
WELCOME AND SO IN REGARDS TO MY
BACKGROUND --
I AM A PRODUCT OF THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM --
FIRST IN MY GENERATION TO GO TO
COLLEGE SO FIRST COLLEGE
GRADUATE CARS COLLEGE STUDENT.
AND HAVE BEEN EDUCATED IN TARLY%
EXCEPT FOR SHORT FORM IN UTAH IN
HERE.
NOT ONLY HAVE I WORKED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WE CATION FOR
NEARLY TWENTY PLUS YEARS WORKING
IN VARIOUS SECTORS --
PRIVATE EDUCATION ON A TWO YEAR
AND FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS AND
MY EXPERIENCE RANGES.
THIS IS MY FIRST STATE IN
GOVERNMENT PER SE --
PRIOR TO THIS I WAS ASSOCIATE
VICE PROVOST AT DREXEL
UNIVERSITY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
RUNNING THAT CAMPUS --
BUT FOR ME IN THIS ROLE --
AS THE BUREAU CHIEF I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO ALSO KNOW
KIND OF THE MISSION AND FOCUS OF
THE BUREAU.
THE BUREAU PROTECTS STUDENTS IN
CONSUMERS TO THE OVERSIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION INDUSTRY BY CONDUCTING
QUALITATIVE REVIEWS OF
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS IN
OPERATION THE STANDARDS FOR
ACTIVELY.
COMBATING UNLICENSED ACTIVITY
IMPARTIALLY RESOLVING STUDENT
AND CONSUMER COMPLAINTS AND
CONDUCTING OUTREACH.
THE VISION OF THE BUREAU'S TO
BECOME THE NATIONAL LEADER
REGARDING PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION AND MAXIMIZING
CALIFORNIA'S CONFIDENCE IN
INSTITUTIONS APPROVED BY THE
BUREAU PROVIDE EQUALITY IN
EDUCATION.
OUR VALUES ARE ACCOUNTABILITY
CONSUMER PROTECTION
EFFECTIVENESS QUALITY INTEGRITY
TRANSPARENCY INCONSISTENCY.
WHEN I CAME INTO THIS ROLE JUST
OVER A YEAR AGO?
MY FOCUS WAS NOT ONLY TO BE ABLE
TO HOLD THE OF OF MOST CONSUMER
PROTECTIVE BUT MAKE SURE THAT
THE BUREAU WAS IN A PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT.
IN COMING INTO THIS I CAME INTO
A PLACE WHERE MORE I WAS A
LITTLE BIT LOW.
STAFFING WAS IN A QUOTE AT THE
ADEQUATE LEVEL TRAINING WASN'T
HAPPENING AS MUCH AS IT SHOULD
BE.
R. T. SYSTEM WAS UNKNOWN AT THAT
POINT WE HAD A MOVE THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT AND WE HAVE TO
START PREPARING FOR TWENTY
TWENTY SUNSET HEARING.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT YOU'LL BE
HEARING A LITTLE BIT OF IN CARS
THAT NEXT --
TESTIMONY.
I CAN SAY IN MY TIME THAT WE'VE
BEEN THERE.
MORALE IS RAISED STAFFING IS
WHEN A TRAINING HAS ALMOST
DOUBLED I. T. SYSTEM HAS A SET
DATE FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
MOVE IS GOING TO BE TAKING PLACE
THIS FALL.
AND WE'RE ALREADY IN
PREPARATIONS FOR OUR TWENTY
TWENTY HEARING. FOR ME AS A
BUREAU CHIEF IS NOT MY TIME IN
IN OR INTEREST TO WASTE TIME IN
MY POSITION HERE MY FOCUS IS
STUDENT PROTECTION IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT TO MY
BACKGROUND IN HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR TWENTY PLUS YEARS.
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
IMPORTANT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND BGP
PORITES REGULATORY STRUCTURE FOR
SCHOOLS THAT SERVE THE SERVANT
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS LIKE MY
SISTER.
STUDENTS THAT DO NOT PURSUE
TRADITIONAL PUBLICAR EDUCATION
PATHS OR STUDENTS THAT HAVE
FOCUS PROFESSIONAL PATHS SUCH AS
ATTENDING NURSING SCHOOL.
OR BECOMING A REGISTERED NURSE.
BBB IS THE GATEKEEPER FOR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO MEET THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS OF A HOME THE
ACADEMIC STANDARDS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS MY GOAL AND MY INTEREST AS
A BUREAU CHIEF TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT IN EVEN STRENGTH IN THOSE
RULES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING THE UP MOST CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
BPP AS DEBBIE SAID FROM --
TEACHES IS A PART OF A TRY AT
OKAY.
IN THAT TRY AT YOU HAD THE US
DEPARTMENT OF THE ACCREDITING
BODIES AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
STATE PROTECTION.
AS A BUREAU CHIEF WHAT WE DO IN
THAT ROLE IS WHERE THE FIRST
GATE KEEPER FOR THOSE
INSTITUTIONS BECOMING --
A CREEK NOT ACCREDITED BUT BEING
LICENSE WITHIN OUR STATE.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS B. B. HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO DENY AN
ORIGINAL LICENSE IF THE
APPLICANT DOES NOT MEET THE
MINIMUM APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS.
SPECIFIC TO THE STATUE AND THE
REGULATE REGULATIONS BABY IS
AUTHORIZED TO DENY LACE LICENSES
WHALE IN THE RENEWAL PROCESS.
IT BB DENIES A LICENSEE OR RENEW
WILL DESTITUTION MUST PROVIDE A
SCHOOL CLOSURE PLAN BASED ON THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT AND OTHER
FACTORS FACTORS.
SECONDLY THE BUREAU IMPORTANT
HAD IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT WHICH
ISN'T TAKEN ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
AS A RESULT OF STUDENT
COMPLAINTS.
BBB HAS SEVERAL TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO ITS THE SPORE DISPOSAL WHEN
IT COMES TO STUDENT COMPLAINTS
THE FIRST ONE IS A NOTICE COMPLY
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO A FIX IT TO
GET YOU HAVE TO THIRTY DAYS TO
RENEW WITH THAT.
THE NEXT ONE IS A CITATION
CITATION CAN BE ANYWHERE FROM
500-100-0200 THOUSAND DEPENDING
ON THE NATURE OF THE CITATION.
NEXIS OUR EMERGENCY DECISIONS.
WHICH IS UNDER GOVERNMENT COLD
EMERGENCY DECISION AS AUTHORITY --
TO IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS FOR THE BILL TO TAKE ACT
ACTIVE IN QUICK --
STEPS WHEN IT COMES --
TO IMMINENT ISSUES AND
INSTITUTIONS ARE IT IS IMMINENT
YES ISSUES WITH ANY SENSE TO
SPARK OCCASION.
LASTLY WHAT WE ALSO HAVE IS
SUSPENSION PROBATION AND THESE
ALL FUND FALL UNDER OUR
ACCUSATIONS WHICH ALSO ALLOWS US
TO REVOKE THE LICENSE.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE MORE DETAIL
WOULD DO ONE ALLOW THE DIRECTOR
TO SPEAK AND AT THIS TIME I WILL
A PAST TO MAKE OF HIM.
A DOCTOR MERION CHAIRS LEYVA
GLAZER DEAN GRIFFEY LOW WITH THE
DEPARTMENT --
THANKS FOR ALLOWING ME THE TIME
TO BE HERE FOR THE AND SHARE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO SUPPORT.
THE BUREAU AND PURSUE OUR
ULTIMATE GOAL OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION. ONE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS IMPORTANT ROLES IS
TO IDENTIFY CHALLENGES AT OUR
PROGRAMS ARE BOARDS IN PARIS AND
JUMP IN ACTION TO HELP.
WHEN THEY'RE STRUGGLING?
WHEN SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
ARISE THE DEPARTMENT POLLS
PEOPLE OFF OUR DAY TO DAY TASKS?
AND TO HELP THEM TOWARDS TURNING
AROUND STRUGGLING FUNCTIONS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING THESE BOARDS AND BUREAUS
UNDER THE DCA UMBRELLA.
WE CAN SWING TEMPORARY RESOURCES
AND EXPERTISE TO PROGRAMS O GET
THEM BACK ON TRACK.
IN OCTOBER OF EIGHTEEN AN
ARTICLE WAS WRITTEN ON BE PP
GIVEN THE BUREAU AND HALF AN
OVERSIGHT.
ALTHOUGH WE BELIEVE THERE WERE
SOME UNFAIR CHARACTERIZATION THE
ARTICLE IT HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED
TO RESTRUCTURE.
AND IMPROVE BPP IS ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS.
IN NOVEMBER OF EIGHTEEN D. C. A.
MET WITH PPP.
THE DEPARTMENT'S DIVISION
INVESTIGATION THE A BY. TO PUT
INTO PLACE AN ACTUAL PLAN TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE AND
ULTIMATELY ELIMINATE BBB'S
COMPLAINTS BACKLOG.
WE JOINTLY CREATED A BPP
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESS THE
BUREAU'S ENFORCEMENT CHALLENGES.
DCA PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING
RESOURCES TO THE TASK FORCE. ONE
COMMANDER FROM DEAR BYE OUR
STONE ARE SWORN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARM. THREE RETIRED ANNUITANTS
FROM THE DAY OF OUR ONE
SUPERVISING INVESTIGATOR FROM
DFI.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FROM THE
OFFICE OF HUMAN RESOURCES TO
ASSIST WITH THE BUREAU'S
RESTRUCTURING.
WHICH DOCTOR MARION WILL SPEAK.
MUST BE TO MORE IN DEPTH AND IN
A MOMENT.
AND ADDITIONAL OFFICE SPACE AT
DC HEADQUARTERS FOR BBB
EMPLOYEES.
THE CA VALUES ALL THE HARD WORK-THAT DOCTOR MARIAN AND HIS TEAM
DOES ON A DAILY BASIS TO PROTECT
STUDENTS.
AND UP HELD CALIFORNIA'S PROMISE
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION.
NOW DOCTOR MERION WILL SPEAK ON
WE'LL SPEAK TO BE P. P.'S RECENT
RESTRUCTURING AND THE TASK
FORCE'S EFFORTS IN THE PAST FEW
MONTHS.
SO WHEN I FIRST CAME TO THE
BUREAU JUST OVER A YEAR AGO I
WAS VERY CLEAR AND SEEING SOME
AREAS THAT THE BUREAU NEED TO
IMPROVE ON AND ONE OF THOSE
AREAS WAS SPECIFICALLY
ENFORCEMENT WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT.
BUT EVEN MORE SO I THOUGHT IT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR THE BOOK THE
ARTICLE TO AN ENTIRE
RESTRUCTURING AND REORGANIZATION
AND WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
IN PROCESS CURRENTLY.
BUT SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO AND
AS DEAN ALLUDED TO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DID WAS NOT ONLY
BRING IN A TEAM TO HELP US THAT
SPECIALIZED ENFORCEMENT BACKLOG.
ARI FORSMAN IMP PARTICULARLY BUT
WE ALSO PRIDE AND RETIRED
ANNUITANTS TO HELP US WITH THAT.
AND NOT ONLY A SENIOR --
ESPECIAL NOT A A SENIOR CAPTAIN
AT THE DCA INDIA BY WE'VE ALL
WHAT BROUGHT IN SOMEBODY FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERTISE IN THIS SPACE.
AND AS YOU WILL SEE IT OUT WHEN
I REPORT LATER IN SOME OF MY
NUMBERS YOU WILL SEE THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT STARTING
IN OCTOBER YOU CAN SEE OUR
ENFORCEMENT NUMBER START TO GO
DOWN ONE OF MY GOALS THIS YEAR
WAS OUR LAST YEAR WAS TO TRY TO
GET OUR ENFORCEMENT NUMBERS DOWN
TO A THOUSAND BACK IN REGARDS TO
A BACKLOG AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
WE ARE PRIOR TO BY THE DAY IN
THE YEAR WHERE WE END UP FALLING
IS A THOUSAND FIFTY SIX ANA
WHICH IS DOWN.
NOW ONCE AGAIN THIS IS CONTINUE
IN THIS IS PART OF OUR OWN
LICENSE ACTIVITY WE PICK FORMED
A NEW UNIT TO FOCUS ON PRIMARILY
ON FORCE AND LICENSE ACTIVITY
FOR STUDENTS.
AND THIS THIS UNIT IS ALREADY A
SELF HAS RAN THROUGH A HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME.
IN ADDITION TO THAT IS IMPORTANT
IN INDIA WHEN WE CAME TWO
THOUSAND NINE OBVIOUSLY I WASN'T
THERE BUT IT ALREADY HAD A BACK
LOG OF EIGHT HUNDRED PLUS.
STUDENT COMPLAINTS WHICH IS
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC FOR
ANYBODY THE MYSELF AND OUR TEAM
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD THE HOW CONVERSATIONS
WITH THIS NEW TASK FORCE WAS.
BEING ABLE TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE PROCESSING TIME.
A LOT OF THE OTHER BUREAUS AND
BOARDS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER HAS FAIRS HAVE I
PROCESS TIME MEETING THAT THAT'S
EITHER A HUNDRED ANDTWENTY DAYS
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY OR NINETY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS WHICH ALLOWS
THE BUREAU ABOARD TO PROCESS.
WHEN A COMPLAINT COMES INTO THE
BUREAU IT IS LOGGED AS A BACKLOG
THAT DAY? FOR THE BUREAU HAS NO
TIME TO PROCESS NOW THIS IS ONE
OF THE THNGS THAT I LEARNED
WHEN I FIRST CAME TO THE BUREAU
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE THE TASK
FORCE IN REGARDS TO BEING ABLE
TO CREATING THIS PRE OF CREATE
THIS -- TASK
FROM PROCESSING TIME FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO FUNCTION IN A WAY
THAT ALLOWS US TO GET TO THESE
COMPLAINTS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND SO BY DOING THAT WHAT WE'VE
ALSO FOCUS ON IS THE INTAKE
PROCESS NOW WHAT HAPPENS IS WHEN
A COMPLAINT COMES IN WE CAN HAVE
SOMEBODY WE HAVE A A STE WE HAVE
STAFF MEMBERS TO TAKE THAT
COMPLAIN IN PLAY REVIEW THAT
COMPLAINT.
BUT THE PROCESS WASN'T AS CLEAN
AS I IT LIKED IT AND SO RIGHT
NOW WORKING WITH THE TASK FORCE
WERE ACTUALLY REVAMPING THAT
PROCESS TO GET A CLEANER PROCESS.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WHEN THESE
COMPLAINTS COME IN THEY ARE
ACTUALLY MAY NOT EVEN NEED TO
COME TO THE BUREAU THEY MAY NEED
TO GO TO ANOTHER BUREAU BOARD.
AND SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO SAY
THAT WE'RE WORKING WILK WITH
GETTING THAT DONE.
SOME OTHER THINGS THAT THE TASK
FORCE IS TAKING ON IS FOCUSING
ON COMPLAINTS IT'S ON THE ONES
THAT ARE WITHIN WHILE THE TASK
FORCE TO FOCUS ON THOSE ONES
THAT ARE AFTER THE FACT.
NOT ONLY THAT ANOTHER PART OF
WHAT THEY'RE FOCUSING ON IS OUR
PROCESS THESE WITHIN THE BUREAU
I FELT LIKE SOME OF THE PROCESS
THAT WE HAD IN PLACE WORDS TO
SYNC.
AND THEIR WITH THEIR EXPERTISE
IN ENFORCEMENT IN BACKGROUND
THEY'RE COMING IN AND LOOKING AT
THIS AND GIVE US A LOT OF
CREATIVE IDEAS THE FOCUS ON
BEING ABLE TO TIGHTEN UP THINGS
WITH ON THAT FOR A FORSMAN SIDE --
ANOTHER THING THAT I ALSOWANT
TO MAKE SURE BRING ATTENTION.
TO IS -- TO
TO TO TO NOT ONLY THAT BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
NUMBERS THAT I WAS TALKING TO
YOU EARLY.
EARLIER MY GOAL WAS TO GET IT TO
UNDER A THOUSAND BY DECEMBER THE
END OF THE YEAR AND WE GOT ENDED
UP IN THE THOUSAND FIFTY SIX
WITH BRINGING ON THE TASK FORCE
AND ALSO CREATING THAN ON
LICENSE ACTIVITY UNIT.
OUR OUR BACKLOG PER SE RIGHT NOW
IS AT SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX NOW THEIR NUMBERS HAVEN'T
BEEN THAT LOW SINCE THE READ
CREATION OF THE BUREAU IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE WHEN HE CAME BACK.
AND SO THOSE ARE EX SICKENING
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THIS THIS --
COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND AND SEE
THAT WE HAD A HUGE TURNAROUND IN
FIVE MONTHS OF MY TIME IN THIS
POSITION FROM GOING FROM A A
LEVIN OR ONE FIFTY EIGHT TO
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
OTHER AREAS THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT TO BE AND WITH THE
DESTRUCTION OF ENFORCEMENT.
WE ALSO BRING IN AND SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR SO THAT WAS PART OF
THIS REAL WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
WITHIN THE BUREAU SO WE'RE
BRINGING IN INDIVIDUALS THAT
FOCUS AND THESE ARE ACTUALLY NEW
POSITIONS THAT I WILL BE HIRING
FOR AN ACTUAL IN THE PROCESS OF
HIRING RIGHT NOW.
SOMEBODY THAT COMES IN THE HAS A
SPECIFIC INTEREST AND BACKGROUND
IN SPECIAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
THIS IS ANOTHER AREA I THINK
THAT THAT THE BUREAU NEEDED
SUPPORT.
AND I THINK WE'RE DOING WELL AND
I THINK WE'LL DO A LOT BETTER
ONCE WE GET THESE INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS POSITION SO NOT ONLY WE
RESTRICTION THE ENFORCEMENT AS A
WHOLE WE'RE ALSO RESTRICTION THE
BUREAU AND SO WE'VE BEEN BUSY.
OVER THESE LAST FEW MONTHS BUT I
THINK YOU CAN SEE IT IN THE
NUMBERS THAT WE ARE TAKING THE
SERIOUS I'M TAKING THE SERIES
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR MERION.
A MYSTICAL FEEL --
DID YOU WANT TO SAY THING ELSE
YES BULLDOZER TESTIMONY MY
TESTIMONIES AND EXCELLENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HERE GLAZER DID
YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
OKAY VERY GOOD ANY QUESTIONS YES
THIRD RAZA.
THANK YOU --
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND
YOU MENTIONED --
CUTTING THE BACKLOG OF THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS.
I'M INTERESTED IN.
WHAT KIND OF COMPLAINTS THEY
WERE?
WHAT WAS THE BOTH BOTH THE
QUALITY OF THEIR COMPLAINTS AS
WELL AS THE QUALITY OF THE
RESOLUTION --
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF WAYS TO
CUT THE BACKLOG WITHOUT REALLY
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM.
AND SO IN THE IN ADDITION TO
LOOKING AT THE NUMBER WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN AS FAR AS THE QUALITY --
THAT WE EXPECT.
FROM THESE INSTITUTIONS.
HOW HAS ADDRESSING ALL THESE
COMPLAINTS WHAT IS IT?
CONCLUDED FOR YOU WHAT IS IT
LEAD YOU TO THINK.
WELL THERE'S A PATTERN HERE AND
A CERTAIN KIND OF COMPLAINT.
THERE'S A PATTERN IN WHICH WOULD
LEAD US.
TO MAKE THIS CHANGE OR RECOMMEND
THIS CHANGE WHAT WHAT'S COME OF
JUST.
RIGHT HERE IN THE DECK HERE SO
GREAT QUESTION I THINK FOR ME
WHAT HAS COME FROM FROM THE
FEEDBACK IN SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH THE
TASK FORCE.
IS THAT.
WE NEED SPECIALIZED --
STAFF WITHIN THAT AREA TO FOCUS
ON THE VARIETY OF COMPLAINTS TO
COME IN THEY'RE VERY SIMPLE
COMPLAINTS WHERE AS YOU KNOW I
DIDN'T GET A BOOK THAT I WAS
PROMISED.
VERSUS YOU KNOW EVEN TO THE MOST
RECENT STUFF WITH --
BRIGHT WOULD --
AROUND YOU KNOW NOT GETTING XIN
CHECK TO BE ABLE TO PAY MY BILL
SO IT VARIES WHEN THOSE
COMPLAINTS COMING THERE SO
THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
THEY CAN GO.
ON EVEN TO FRAUD AND SO FOR ME
ONCE AGAIN IT'S ABOUT GETTING A
STAFF IN THERE THAT'S QUALIFIED
TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THAT Y.
LANES OF BEING ABLE TO SEE WHAT
TYPE OF KEL PLACES ARE AND DEAL
WITH THEM IN A TIMELY MANNER SO
THE I WAS.
SAFE STAFFING IS PROBABLY IN THE
RIGHT STAFFING IS PROBABLY THE
MOST CRITICAL THING FOR ME THAT
I'VE NOTICED S WE STARTED TO GO
THROUGH THESE THINGS.
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
GLAZER --
WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY --
JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON SENATOR
RISES POINT --
IN THE MATERIAL THAT YOU
PROVIDED TO US THERE IS REALLY
NO BREAKDOWN IN THE SUBJECT
AREAS IN WHICH THE COMPLAINTS
HAVE BEEN.
SUBMITTED YOU HAVE NUMBERS BUT
YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
SUBSTANCE OF IT WHY IS THAT.
OUT WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS WE'VE REPORT EVERY MONTH
OR EVERY QUARTER AT OUR ADVISORY
MEETING.
AND SO WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION
I CAN EASILY PROVIDED TO YOU BUT
I BY TALKING ABOUT THE NUMBERS
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE CATEGORIES
IN WHICH COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN
FILED.%
RIGHT THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING WE
HAVE A WE HAVE A TOP FIVE THAT-PROVIDES THAT INFORMATION THAT
WE CAN EASILY GET THE
INFORMATION OVER TO YOU I DON'T
KNOW THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS REQUESTED THAT'S FOR
EASIER ENOUGH.
AND DO YOU HAVE A BROKEN DOWN BY
SCHOOLS IN WHICH THE COMPLAINTS
ARE TOO NO.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT --
AND WHY IS THAT WOULD THAT ARMED
OCCASION OF A PROBLEM IF YOU GOT
IT.
A LARGER THAN.
NORMAL COMPLAINTS FROM ONE
PARTICULAR SCHOOL NOW THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
PUBLICIZE BECAUSE THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION COULD JEOPARDIZE
THAT SO WE DON'T WE WOULDN'T
PUBLISH THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION.
I SEE WHAT'S HARD FOR US TO
KINDA DO EXIT YOU KNOW YOU YOU
DO IN YOUR REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE YOU DO PROVIDE.
SOME SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF AND
FOR THAT YOU'RE.
IN SILICON VALLEY UNIVERSITY
SOUTH BAY LOW UNIVERSITY GAVE
TWO CASES THERE --
SO THAT'S HELPFUL BUT THIS --
WHAT TRYING TO GET THE BIG
PICTURE HERE AT IT DOESN'T MAKE
IT EASY TO DO THAT --
HOW MANY --
LICENSES DO YOU TURN DOWN IN THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR.
HOW MANY LICENSES THAT WE TURNED
DOWN I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER?
FOR YOU BUT I CAN EASILY GET ON
AVERAGE --
SO YOU SHOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER
OF PENDING.
APPLICATIONS FOR LICENSES.
RIGHT YOU SHOW THAT.
IN. TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN YOU
ELEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
PENDING AN INVENTOR OF EIGHTEEN
YOU HAD A HUNDRED FORTY TWO SO I
GUESS I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THEN WHAT'S THE QUALITY ELEMENTS
OF THOSE NUMBER REDUCTIONS IS
BECAUSE HE SAID DEL.
OUR YOU SAID YES QUICKER.
SO AT FIRST OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW I
WAS HERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND SO
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE WHAT I WAS ABLE TO DO
WHICH I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT.
COMING INTO THIS ROLE THEY DID
NOT HAVE A CHIEF FOR ALMOST A
YEAR AND A HALF IN OUR LICENSING
UNIT AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS I DID COMING INTO
THIS ROLE IS GETTING SOMEBODY IN
THERE TO HELP RUN THAT UNIT.
AND I THINK PROBABLY WHAT MAY
HAVE HAPPENED DURING THAT TIME
IS THAT WE JUST TIGHTEN UP
THINGS MOM THAT WOULD BE MY
ASSUMPTION AT THIS POINT WITHOUT
BEING ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS CLEARLY.
BUT KNOWING THAT OUR STAFF KNOW
OUR STAFFING LEVELS WERE DOWN
WHEN I FIRST CAME TO THE BUREAU --
IN BEING ABLE TO UP THE STAFFING
NO POTENTIALLY WHY YOU'VE SEEN
SOME OF THE NUMBERS CHANGE.
SO WE HEARD EARLIER TESTIMONY
FROM -- MS --
COCHRAN SHEIDENTIFIED A NUMBER
OF AREAS IN WHICH SHE THOUGHT
THAT -- OUR
OUR WORK WAS ENDANGERED BY
FEDERAL ACTION --
ENDANGERED BY --
ISSUES OF ACCREDITATION --
ONLINE.
ENROLLMENT FOR OUT OF STATE
[inaudible]
COLLEGES --
AND ENDANGERED BY MISLEADING
DATA PROVIDED BY A NUMBER OF
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS YOU SAT
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM IN AND
LISTEN TO THAT.
ARE THOSE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD FOR THE FIRST TIME NO
THESE ARE ACTUALLY HAVE HAD SOME
CONVERSATION WITH THE CASE AND
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT SUPPORTERS IN
MYANMAR ROSE BUREAU CHIEF IN
BEING ABLE TO HELP SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION QUITE HONEST.
AND SO NO IT WASN'T THE FIRST
TIME I'VE HEARD IF YOU LOOK IN
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE RULES FOR
THE BRIDE THE BUREAU SOME OF
THESE THINGS ARE SUCH THAT ALLOW --
I DON'T SEE ALLOW THAT
POTENTIALLY LIMIT US SO TO SPEAK
TO THE ONE TO THE ONLINE
EDUCATION RIGHT --
WE ARE ABLE TO DO ENFORCEMENT
BUT IT'S IT'S NOT INFORMED SO
BASICALLY THE SCHOOLS OUT OF
STATE ONLINE SCHOOLS ARE
REQUIRED. TO REGISTER WITH US BE
ACCREDITED AND PAIN IS TRUTH AND
THAT'S THE LIMIT OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONS.
THOSE ARE THE THREE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE.
THAT WE ABIDE BY IT BUT THAT
DOESN'T ALLOW WE DON'T WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO DO ANY ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT ON TOP OF THAT AND
SO.
IN SUPPORT OF WHAT YOU SAY AND I
HAVE I I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THAT AND ACTUALLY SUPPORTED TO
BE QUITE HONEST.
THEY ARE TURNOUT SO THESE OUT OF
STATE INSTITUTIONS --
PRESUMABLY OR MAYBE NOT SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE REGISTERED OR
LICENSED IN OTHER STATES.
BUT THEY ALSO THEY'RE AT THEIR
CREDIT IT IN LICENSE AND DO AND
PAYING THE STRIP. FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO TO WORK WITH THEM BUT WE
HAVE NO OVERSIGHT INSOFAR AS
GOING TO THE STATE IN BEING ABLE
TO DO ANY ENFORCEMENT ON I GOT
UP AND WE CAN DO.
THANK YOU CAN BE AWARE OF
ENFORCEMENTACTIONS THAT ARE
BEING TAKEN IN THE STATE'S
AGAINST THOSE INSTITUTIONS WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF
THAT.
YES BUT WE STILL WOULD BE ABLE
TO TAKE ACTION.
I HATED IT AND I I LOVE IT BUT
IT ALL DEPENDS ON HOW YOU DEFINE
ACTION.
AND BY TO FIND ACTION YOU MEAN
YOUR ABILITY TO STEP IN WITH
THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND AND FOR
SOME SORT OF ACTIONS AGAINST
THEM BUT ABSOLUTE BUT YOU'D ALSO
BE IN A POSITION TO LET STUDENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA NOW ABOUT
ISSUES.
THAT YOU BECAME AWARE OF ABOUT
THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND OTHER
STATES WE ARE LAWS VERY LIMITING
IN THAT IS THAT STUDENT HARM HAS
TO OCCUR.
MEETING THAT SUCKS SO BRIGHT
WOULD I THINK WAS THE MOST
RECENT --
ONE THE BRIGHT WOULD WOULD --
WHO'S IN DECEMBER --
ON MY GOODNESS ARGOSY SORRY.
ARGOSY SO MANY OF THE SCHOOL SO
ARGOSY JUST OCCURRED RIGHT.
IN SO WHAT HAPPENED WITH ARGOSY
IS THAT.
SOME SO THE STATE SO THE FEDERAL
STATE TOOK STEPS IN REGARDS TO
TURN IT CUTTING OFF THEIR TITLE
FOR FUNDING.
BUT AT THAT POINT TIME IT WAS
NOTHING WITHIN THE BUREAU'S LAW
THAT WILL ALLOW THE BUREAU TO
TAKE ACTION.
BECAUSE WE IT WASN'T ANY.
INTIMATE STUDENTS ARE.
IT WASN'T ANY STUDENT HEART WE
HAD A AFTER THE HOME OR HAPPEN
FOR US TO REACT TO THE STUDENTS.
THAT'S THE LIMITATION OF OUR LAW.
THAT MAKES SENSE AT THE
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT'S A
CALIFORNIA LAW I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE CHANGES IN THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
BE LOOKING AT THE BILL SO ALL
THE BUREAUS LAWS A WHOLE I THINK
THAT'S CRITICAL.
AS I THINK I'D BE INTERESTED IN --
I WOULD GUESS THAT MY COLLEAGUES
MIGHT BE AS WELL.
OF ANY SPECIFIC PROPOSALS YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE THE CHANGE OUR LAWS
TO BETTER PROTECT OUR STUDENTS
RIGHT I WOULD I THINK IT WOULD
BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REALLY LOOK AT ALL THE LAWS
WITHIN THE BUREAU NO QUESTION.
WELL THAT I'LL MAKE THAT AS A
PENDING REQUESTS AND FOR ME AT
LEAST IS THAT WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN.
YOUR EXPERTISE AND INSIGHT AS TO
WAYS WE COULD CHANGE OUR LAWS TO
BETTER PROTECT STUDENTS IN
REGARD TO OUT OF STATE.
ONLINE COLLEGES.
BOB I'M EXCITED ABOUT THAT OKAY
VERY GOOD YOU ALSO RAISE THIS
ISSUE OF WELL THE THE ISSUE OF
ACCREDITATION HAS COME UP AND
YOU SAID YOU FOLLOW THAT AS WELL.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU THINK
YOU SHOULD BE DOING OR WE SHOULD
BE DOING COLLECTIVELY ON THAT
ISSUE OR YOU HAVE DONE ON THAT
ISSUE GREAT QUESTION SO ONE OF
THE THINGS FOR ME THAT I HAVE AN
INTEREST IN DOING IN TRYING TO
DO IS STRENGTHENING THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
THE TRIAD AND SO THAT'S BETWEEN
THE CREDITORS AND THE U. S. D.
O. E. WE ALL KINDA WORK
SEPARATELY BUT IF ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE DONE IN MY TIME
IS TRYING TO STRENGTHEN THAT
RELATIONSHIP.
I THINK YOU CAN CERTAINLY GET
BETTER --
AND I'M WORKING TOWARDS IT SEEMS
THAT IF YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
ACTIONS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN BY
THE ADMINISTRATION IN THIS AREA
WOULD IT BE FAIR TO SAY YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROPOSED
ACTIONS BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
I'M SORRY THEIR ACCREDITATION
ARE YOU CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE ACTIONS BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION REGARD TO
CHANGING THE PRACTICE OF
ACCREDITATION --
ABSOLUTELY I'M ALMOST STUDENT
CENTERED ADMINISTRATOR I'M
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT MAY COME IN THE PLACE THAT
AFFECT OUR STUDENTS ARE
CONSUMERS OF OUR CALIFORNIA
ABSOLUTELY THE HAS THE BUREAU
TAKING ANY ACTIONS TO INITIATE
ANY COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES ABOUT.
WHY YOU THINK THEIR ACTIONS
WOULD DIMINISH THE QUALITY OF
DEGREES FOR OUR STUDENTS NO I
DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT'S OUR
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO TO MOVE
FORWARD BUT I CAN I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT MY INTERCESSOR A BUREAU
CHIEF IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING THE?
BEST THAT WE CAN WITHIN THE
POWERS THAT WE HAVE OKAY AND I
KNOW YOU DO WORK IN A
BUREAUCRACY IN YOUR NEW.
I'LL TELL YOU IT WOULDN'T
SURPRISE YOU TO HEAR THAT I
THINK I'VE SEEN OUR CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION WEIGH IN ON A
VARIETY OF THINGS IN REGARD TO
THE LIMóN SITUATION --
THAT THEY THINK HE IS SUCH
COMING UP SHORT.
I WULD ENCOURAGE YOU AND YOUR
OTHERS OTHERS WITHIN.
THE THE GOVERNMENT TO WELL WORK
TOGETHER TO TO CALL.
ATTENTION TO THESE.
ABSOLUTELY THIS THE MANAGEMENT --
AND AND WHAT ABOUT IN THE ISSUE
OF THE OUTCOMES FALSE OUTCOMES --
SAID MISLEADING AND DECEPTIVE
RECRUITMENT THIS IS AGAIN WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS RAISED
EARLIER YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT ABSOLUTELY SO MADE TO ME
THIS IS SICKENING TO BE QUITE
HONEST -- I
WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR THE FORMER
GOVERNOR TO BE ON CALIFORNIA'S
TO NAY COMMISSION SO I WAS ABLE
TO SEE A LOT OF HOW THE STUDENTS
ARE AFFECTED THE I. T. T. IS AN
ILL SOME OF THESE.
IN SIENA SO FOR ME ABSOLUTELY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT OUR STUDENTS ON IN OUR
CONSUMERS BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
ON OUR PART.
THAT OUR LAWS ARE SUCH THAT
ALLOW US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
LICENSING INSTITUTIONS THAT
ALLOW THAT ARE BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
NEED FOR OUR STUDENTS AND SO
SOME OF THE DATA THAT'S CALLED
ARE SOME OF THE DATA THAT'S
GIVEN TO THE BUREAU IS SELF.
PURPORTED DATA.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOTHING WE NONE OF
OUR LAWS ALLOW FORCES SAY THAT
IT NEEDS TO BE AUDITED OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
AND SO FOR US ALL WE CAN DO IS
ACCEPT THE INFORMATION THAT'S
BEEN REPORTED TO US.
SO I I GUESS WHAT I'D LIKE TO
ASK IS MY FINAL THOUGHT WOULD BE
THAT IT WOULD BE GREAT IF THE IF
THE BUREAU AND DCA COULD COME
BACK TO US WITH SPECIFIC
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS. TO
ADDRESS A NUMBER OF THESE
SHORTCOMINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY AND MAYBE IN
SUBSEQUENT TESTIMONY --
ALL WITH THE IDEA THAT WE'RE
HERE IN THE SAME DIRECTION HERE
WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR STUDENTS
WHO WANT THEM TO ACHIEVE --
THEIR BEST GOALS A AND A WAY
THAT -- IS
FAIR APPROPRIATE AFFORDABLE AND
ALL THE REST BUT I THINK WHAT --
I GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT.
WE NEED THE BUREAU TO BE DOT
JUST DAY IN ENFORCER OF SOMEONE
WHO'S MADE A MISTAKE AND WE FIND
OUT ABOUT IT AFTER THE FACT
THEY'RE CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT YOU PLAY IN THAT.
BUT WE WANT TO BE PRO ACTIVE IN
IDENTIFYING THESE ISSUES I HAD A
TIME AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE LAWS.
AND THE REGULATIONS TO ALLOW YOU
TO DO YOUR JOB.
BEFORE THE HARM HAPPENS AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE I THINK THAT
WE HAVE MUTUAL INTERESTS AND WE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA AKA COME
OF THE HOPE YOU I WOULD.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER CENTER
PAN.
THANKS THANKS VERY MUCH A TO A
CLEAR FIGHT.
SO THE CURRENT LAW AND WE'RE
TALKING YEAH WE WITH A
CONVERSATION I SHARE US OUR
GLAZERS DESIRE FOR FOR FOR
GUIDANCE FROM THE BUREAU IN
TERMS OF A LOSS TO MAKE YOU MORE
EFFECTIVE BUT IS IT CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT HARM HAS.
THROUGH KERR DOES THAT.
CAN OCCUR TO ANY STUDENT
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF
THESE ONLINE ORGANIZATIONS THEIR
OPERATE MULTIPLE STATES OR DOES
THAT ACTUALLY HAVE.
TO THE ARMY HAS HAPPENED ON
ONLINE.
ON GROUND ON GROUND STUDENTS.
OKAY BECAUSE WE WE DON'T HAVE
LAWS THAT WILL ALLOW US TO TAKE
ACTION ON ONLINE OKAY SO OKAY
BUT A POLITICALLY BUT THAT
NUMBER TO DOES IT HAVE TO SO YOU
HAVE A MULTI STATE OPERATOR AND
THERE'S HARM TO HAPPEN TO A
STUDENT AT OTHER STATE.
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO ACT BASED ON
THAT OR DO YOU HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL HARM HAPPENS TO LOOK
STUDENT CALLOW AND WHEN IT COMES
TO ONCE AGAIN WHEN IT COMES TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WE CAN WORK
WITH THE BUT INCOMES TO OUT OF
STATE INSTITUTIONS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US. TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE ACTIONS ON HOW TO STAY
OFTEN AS WITH THE REGULATORY
ISN'T AGENTS IN THOSE STATES.
BUT IT HAS A BY THE CALIFORNIA --
SO AND ARE YOU TELL ME DARK
MULTI STATE OPERATORS OR YES A
LOT OF THE THINGS OF THAT OUT SO
RIGHT SO THERE'S A MULTI STATE
OPERATOR DOES HARM YOU DOWN IF I
HAPPENED TO SEE LET'S SAY IN
COLORADO OR ANOTHER STRIKE RIGHT.
CAN YOU ACT TO THEN ARE A WE
HAVE TO WAIT TILL HARM ACTUALLY
EPISODE CALIFORNIA STUDENT WE
ACTUALLY CAN'T WE CAN'T IF IT'S
OUT OF STATE STUDENT WE CAN'T WE
ENGAGED THAT ABOUT AS A MULTI
STATE OPERATORS NOSE OPERATES IN
CALIFORNIA IN ANOTHER STATE THAT
THE HARM HAPPENED TO A STUDENT.
IN ANOTHER STATE.
FIRST CAN YOU THEN ACT OR DO YOU
HAVE TO WAIT TO THE HARM HAPPENS
FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENT.
IF I I THINK I UNDERSTAND IF I
UNDERSTAND YOU CLEARLY RIGHT.
IF IT'S A CALIFORNIA STUDENT.
IT IS A NOT A CALIFORNIA STATE
IF THERE IS NOT A CALIFORNIA TO
THE NOW BECAUSE IT'S NOT A EVEN
SO EVEN THOUGH YOU KNOW THEIR
QUEUE COMMITTING HARD TO THE
WORDS THEY'RE COMMITTEE ACTIONS
THAT LED TO A HARM TO A STUDENT
IN ANOTHER STATE.
THAT'S ALL THE STATE OPERATED A
OPERATE CALIFORNIA YOU STILL
CAN'T DO ANYTHING THA'S WHEN WE
WOULD CONTACT THE REGULATORY
BODY IN THAT STATE.
OKAY BUT OKAY LET ME ASK YOU
KNOW.
OKAY BECAUSE MAYBE DOCTOR PANAMA
HE WOULD KNOW BETTER AND%
SPECIFIC TO LIKE A MEDICAL
LICENSE WELL I'M OF I'M SAYING
IS THAT SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THERE'S A HARM THAT HAPPENED
RIGHT THE THAT THIS INSTITUTIONS
A MULTI STATE INSTITUTION RIGHT.
IT HAS CERTAIN POLICIES IT DOES
CERTAIN THINGS RIGHT AND IT DOES
IT ACROSS THE INSTITUTION IS THE
INSTITUTIONAL POLICY.
AND IT LED TO HARM TO THE
STUDENT IN THAT.
UNIVERSE AND THAT COLLEGE BUT IN
ANOTHER STATE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE HARM
ACTUALLY HAS TO HAPPEN TO A
CALIFORNIA'S NORTH THIS POLICY
CAUSE HARM.
BUT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN TO A
CALIFORNIA STUDENT YET IT ACTS
ON THAT.
UNIVERSITY TO SAY YOU NEED TO
CHANGE THE WAY YOU DO THINGS ARE
AT CETERA OR DO YOU HAVE TO WAIT
TILL THIS HARM TO A CALIFORNIA
SO GOOD FOR THE SAME REASONS.
ARE AS I UNDERSTAND
UNFORTUNATELY DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENTS REACH IS CONFINED TO
THE START CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
YES OKAY RIGHT RIGHT USE OF THIS
STUDENT REGARDLESS OF THE
INSTITUTION.
BEING A MULTI STATE INSTANCE
STARTS YOU CAN'T ACT RIGHT AS AS
MENTALLY I JUST Y. CLARIFIES
THAT YOU CANNOT ACT EVEN WHEN
YOU KNOW HARM IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN
AND HARM HAS HAPPENED.
BUT IT HAPPENED TO HAVE THE KERR
OUT OF STATE FIRST.
OKAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN DOCTOR ARE
EXCUSE ME --
CENTER ARCHULETA ONE SECOND SO
YOU WOULD NOT EVEN WARNED THE
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
I WANNA MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR ON
THAT.
YOU YOU CANNOT ACT I'M FOLLOWING
UP ON DR PANTS QUESTION YOU
CANNOT ACT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE A HARM DID NOT HAPPEN TO
THE STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE
KNOW MAYBE IN THE TWENTY OTHER
STATES THAT THEY'RE OPERATING
THERE'S A PROBLEM.
CAN YOU WORE IN THE STUDENT IN
CALIFORNIA HEY THIS COULD HAPPEN
TO YOU IT DOESN'T ALLOW BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENS IS IF I'M A A
BUSINESS OR CORPORATION.
BASICALLY WHAT WE COULD BE DOING
IS UNDERCUTTING THAT BUSINESS
INCORPORATION ENACT AND IT'S NO
HARM TO CALIFORNIA STUDENT YET
AT A FOR US THAT FIRST BILL TAKE
ACTION IT HAS TO BE HOME.
SO WE WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAN
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU CHIEF --
FOR BEING HERE --
MADAM CHAIR MY QUESTION.
PERTAINS TO OUR VETERANS BECAUSE
PRESENT --
OVERSEAS --
I WOULD SAY LAW ENFORCEMENT
GENERAL ENFORCEMENT IN GENERAL
MAKING SURE THE STUDENTS ARE
PROTECTED --
AND SO ON IN THERE ARE TWO
ISSUES THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT.
ANY SCHOOL IS TRYING TO PROMOTE
ITSELF OF FOR PROFIT GAIN
WHETHER IT WOULD BE BUT THERE IS
NO.
ACTUAL JOB T THE OTHER END
THAT'S NUMBER ONE AND THE AND
THE CALVET THE VETERAN.
WHO'S USING HIS --
GI BILL TO OBTAIN IS EDUCATION --
HOW ARE YOU WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S PROTECTED GOOD THAT
FEDERAL STATE?
AND THESE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT OUR
YOUNG VETERANS.
YOU GUYS ARE ALL BRING ENOUGH
GREAT QUESTIONS BECAUSE THIS IS
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
INTO BECAUSE REMEMBER.
CAL VET IS A SEPARATE
ORGANIZATION TO BE PP WHICH THEY
OPERATE UNDER DIFFERENT LAWS AND
WE OPERATE UNDER SO THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO TAKE ACTION ON GI BILLS.
THAT MAY NOT FALL WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF THE BUREAU.
AND SO THIS IS ANOTHER AREA THAT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT IN MY
OPINION BECAUSE IT AS OBVIOUSLY
WE WANT O BOTH TAKE ACTION AT
THE SAME TIME BUT THE WAY THAT
OUR LAWS ARE STRUCTURED DON'T
ALLOW FOR US TO DO THAT.
RIGHT IT'S SO WHAT WE TRY TO DO
IS WORK TOGETHER --
WITH CAL DATING YOU I'M SURE
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT WHEN
SCOTT COMES UP TO TALK ABOUT --
SAR BUT ONCE AGAIN THE WAY THAT
OUR LAW WAS OR SUCH THEY MAY BE
A TAKE ACTION BEFORE WE AT MAKE
TAKE ACTION BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN
GOING BACK TO THE STUDENT HARM
PART.
IT MAY NOT REACH THE LEVEL TO
OUR LAW.
BUT I WOULD THINK WE WOULD HAVE
A FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY --
IF YOU HAVE ANY KNOWLEDGE OF A
PENDING PROBLEM THAT YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO THE STUDENTS STATE
A CALIFORNIA --
DID TO BE POINTED OUT AND THERE
SHOULD BE A PROCESS AND
PROCEDURE TO NOTIFY THE ENTITY
EVEN THOUGH IT'S OUT OF STATE.
OR WHEREVER IT MIGHT BE THAT
SOMETHING IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN OR
HAS HAPPENED AND IT MAY JUST
AGAIN IT'S THE STUDENT WHO IS
HURT TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
PRESS ME GET FULL COMING FROM A
COLLEGE CAMPUS WHERE I'VE WORKED
THE MAJORITY OF MY LIFE.
IN BEING ABLE TO NOT TAKE ACTION
IN SEE THESE THINGS OCCUR IS ONE
OF THE HARDEST THINGS THAT I'VE
HAD IN THIS ROLE.
THE BE VERY CLEAR WITH THAT.
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
SO.
WE CAN WORK ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES YOU HAVE WITH NOT BEING
ABLE TO DO SOMETHING BECAUSE
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW BUT LET'S
GO BACK TO WHAT YOU DO HAVE
DIRECT CONTROL OVER --
HE SAID WHEN YOU FIRST TOOK OVER
THAT THERE WERE SOME ENFORCEMENT
CHALLENGES WHAT WERE THOSE
CHALLENGES.
I WOULD SAY THE FIRST THE FIRST
THING WAS STAFFING.
OKAY OKAY STAFF WHAT REGARDS
WERE STAFFING LEVELS WERE LOW
ALL IN IN THAT UNIT RIGHT AND
THEN TRAINING --
WE WERE RECEIVING TRAINER BUT I
THINK FOR ME THIS IS UP HAS TO
BE A ONGOING THING TO BE QUITE
HONEST.
AND THEN THE THIRD THING IS
GETTING PEOPLE IN THOSE
POSITIONS THAT SPECIALIZE IN
SPECIAL INVESTIGATIONS I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE A GAME
CHANGER FOR THE BUREAU TO BE
QUITE HONEST.
IN BEING ABLE TO DO SOME OF THIS
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING VERY GOOD
SO WHAT IS YOUR AVERAGE TIME TO
CLOSE A COMPLAINT.
THAT'S THE NUMBER I'M GONNA HAVE
TO LOOK UP FOR YOUNG BUT MY
APOLOGIES.
SO.
DO YOU WHEN I COME IN AND I HAVE
A CLAIM I HAVE A COMPLAINT IS
THERE SOMEONE SPECIFIC THAT I
TALKED TO HOW MANY OKAY AND HOW
MANY INVESTIGATORS DO YOU HAVE
RIGHT.
SO YOU WOULD DEFINITELY TALK TO
SOMEBODY ON WHEN YOU COME IN I
THINK OUR INVESTIGATION NUMBERS
ARE AROUND. THIRTEEN I THINK IS
THE NUMBER RIGHT NOW.
AND I CAN GET YOU ONCE AGAIN I
CAN CONFIRM THOSE NUMBERS WERE.
SO I COMMAND AND I REGISTER MY
COMPLAINT.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS NEXT SO
YOU'LL GET A A LETTER BACK FROM
US OR JUST SOMETHING CONFIRMING
THAT WE HAD COMMUNICATION OKAY
JUST SAYING HEY YOU'RE COMPLAIN
IT'S BEEN RECEIVED.
AND FROM THERE WE STARTED
INVESTIGATING AND SO --
TYPICALLY BEGIN BE WHEN THOSE
THINGS WHERE --
DEPENDING ON THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE COMPLAINT IT COULD BE ONE
THOSE THINGS AS BONTA TOP
PRIORITY --
BASED ON ARE STATUES OR CAN BE
SOMETHING THAT JUST GOES TO THE
TYPICAL PROCESS --
OF REVIEWING.
AND DO YOUR OWN AGENTS OR WHAT
WOULD YOU CALL THESE FOLKS
INVESTIGATORS.
DO THEY KNOW IS THIS IS THIS A
PRIORITY FOR THEM --
ABSOLUTELY OKAY IT'S IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR US BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS IN THIS IS ANOTHER THING
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE IN
SPEAKING TO ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE
A HIGH TURNOVER RIGHT IN THAT
ENFORCEMENT YOU'D.
FIND THAT WE'RE TRYING TO CHANGE
RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK I HEARD
YOU SAY THAT THE THE LONGEST OR
THE AVERAGE WAS THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE DAYS FOR
COMPLAIN WHAT WAS THAT I DIDN'T
I NEVER SAID THE AVERAGE US THAT
WE ARE FOCUSING ON THAT TASK
FORCE WERE.
LOOKING AT CASES THAT WERE OF
HOW MANY DO YOU HAVE THEIR ABOVE
THREE AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS SO
TOTAL WE HAVE GAVE YOU THE
NUMBER IS. THOUSAND FIFTY SIX
FORTY SIX OR SEVEN OKAY THAT WAS
A SEVEN HUNDRED NUMBER SEVEN
FORTY SIX I CAN'T TELL YOU BASED
ON THE NUMBER THAT I HAVE HERE
BUT THAT'S EASY ENOUGH REPORT WE
HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
IN THE REASON I'M ASKING ALL
THIS TO BE MY OLD LIFE BEFORE I
CAME HERE I WAS THE PRESIDENT MY
UNION BEFORE THAT I WAS A UNION
REPRESENTATIVE.
SO WE DID SOMETHING CALLED
GRIEVANCES WHICH IS VERY SIMILAR
TO COMPLAINTS AND SO IT WAS MY
JOB AS A UNION REP TO GET THOSE
INVESTIGATED AND TURNED OVER AND
GET A RESOLUTION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE MEMBER OR
IN THIS CASE A STUDENT IS
WAITING.
SO NOW THEN WHEN I BECAME THE
PRESIDENT OF MY UNIT WAS MY JOB
TO MAKE SURE THAT MY UNION WRAPS
WERE TURNING OVER AND GETTING
THEIR GRIEVANCES RESOLVED SO DO
YOU GET INVOLVED TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THEY ARE INVESTIGATING AND
TURNING THESE OVER AND GETTING
SOME SORT OF SATISFACTION TO THE
STUDENTS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE I
THINK WITH THE QUESTION YOU'RE
ASKING WAS ANSWERED IN REGARDS
TO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
THIS BIG CHANGE RIGHT NOW WITH
AN ENFORCEMENT AND THE BUREAU AS
A WHOLE.
BECAUSE I GOT INVOLVED.
SO YES YOU DO ABSOLUTELY OKAY
ABSOLUTELY AND WHEN YOUR
INVESTIGATORS ARE INVESTIGATING
IF THERE'S EVER ANYTHING THAT
STANDS OUT SOMETIMES WHEN WE
USED INVESTIGATE GRIEVANCES WE
WOULD FIND THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING HAPPENING.
THAT WE WEREN'T AWARE OF AND SO
THEN IT WOULD CAUSE US TO DO OUR
OWN INVESTIGATION SO DO YOU EVER
HAVE A STUDENT COME TO MAKE A
COMPLAINT THAT YOU FIND SO
AGREED SHOWS.
THAT YOU WOULD INVESTIGATE THE
SCHOOL YES SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WILL BE DOING MOVING
FORWARD WITH.
IS PAYING A LITTLE BIT MORE
ATTENTION TO FRAUD.
A AND IN PARTICULAR VOUCHERS
FRAUD SO YES ABSOLUTELY I WOULD
SAY IS PAY PAY A LOT MORE
ATTENTION TO FRAUD.
I MEAN THESE POOR STUDENTS AS
WITH MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
STATED THE YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS
CAN RUIN THEIR LIFE IF THE
SCHOOLS ARE DOING IT PROPERLY.
QUESTION RECALL RIGHT YES DIDN'T
MENTION THAT --
CURRENT LAWS DO ALLOW THE BUREAU --
TO GO ROUTE OF AN EMERGENCY
ORDER IF IN FACT WE BELIEVE THE
STUDENT IS IN IMMINENT.
DANGER ARE OKAY VERY GOOD BUT
YOU COULD DO IF A STATE AN OUT
OF STATE SCHOOL THAT ALSO
OPERATES IN CALIFORNIA.
HAD BEEN SOMETHING FRAUDULENT
HAD DONE SOMETHING TO STUDENTS
IN ANOTHER STATE YOU COULD TAKE
NO PROACTIVE ACTION ANOTHER
STATE NOW SO YOU JUST SIT THERE
GO GOSH I FEEL SO BAD FOR ALL
THOSE STUDENTS OVER THERE THIS
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA EVEN THOUGH
I HAVE THIS INFORMATION.
I CAN'TSHARE WITH THEM I I
NEVER SIT THERE LIKE THAT --
ACTS OKAY GOOD.
NEVER WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT
WHAT CAN WE DO FOR THE STUDENTS
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
FRUSTRATION UP HERE THAT YOU
KNOW THE LAW WON'T LET US DO IT
THE LAW WON'T LET US DO IT.
WHAT CAN YOU DO RIGHT SO I THINK
WHICH CHU I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
I'M CLEAR IS AN I DIDN'T TAKE
THIS JOB TO SIT ON MY HANDS?
OKAY AND I TO DESIGN A BIG ANY
OF US TOOK OUR JOB FOR THAT
REASON EITHER O FOR ME AND YOU
CAN SEE IN THE LAST YEAR AND A-HALF EARLIER CHANGE THAT I'VE
BEEN THERE THAT WE'RE MAKING A
CHANGE.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO THINGS AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT ARE
LIMITING US IN BEING ABLE TO DO
THAT AND WHICH IS WHY I'M HAPPY
AND I BROUGHT IT HERE IN SO WE
CAN MAKE SOME CHANGES.
THANK YOU THE WELCOME CENTER
GLAZER DID HAVE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS.
WILL DR MIRANDA.
I I GUESS Và MY UNDERSTANDING
OF THE LAW THAT IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN YOURS AND I WANT
TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
THE THE STATUTE THAT CREATED THE
OFFICE OF STUDENT ASSISTANCE AND
RELIEF.
AND IN THAT IT SAYS THAT THE
DUTIES OF THAT OFFICER WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM THE DIRECTOR
JUST A MOMENT SO I LOOK FOR TO
THEIR INSIGHT BUT I'LL IT'S
IMPORTANT I SHARE THIS WITH YOU
THAT.
PART OF THE DUTIES OF THAT
OFFICE.
OUR TO OUTREACH TO STUDENTS.
CONCERNING INDUSTRY TRENDS AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
THAT'S PART OF THE DUTIES.
OKAY IS TO SEE PROBLEMS AND LET
STUDENTS BE AWARE OF THOSE
PROBLEMS.
SO I THINK THAT --
I THINK EVEN LOOKING WITH
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT EXIST IN
YOUR BUREAU AND WITH YOUR OFFICE
YOU HAVE THAT ABILITY NOW IN MY
OPINION.
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THAT SURE I TO BE
MORE PROACTIVE IN THESE AREAS
IT'S A PART OF THE CHARGE TO
THAT OFFICE.
AND I THINK IT'S A PART OF YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND I THINK YOU
WOULD SAW THAT IN THE STEPS THAT
WE TOOK IN ARGOSY.
AND HERE RECENTLY BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR WE
HAVE TO BASED ON THE LAW THAT WE
HAVE.
IT APPEARS FROM OUR FROM OUR
LEGAL INTERPRETATIONS TO ME IS
THAT THEY'RE VERY LIMITING A
STEP THAT WE TAKE BUT IN THE
ARGOSY CASE WHAT WE DID DO IS WE
DID SEND OUT.
OUR SO OUR STAFF AND OUR BUREAU
STAFF TO THESE INSTITUTIONS IN
PROVIDED WITH AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION BUT WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT WE DOING THAT
WERE WALKING THE THIN LINE.
AND FOR ME I DON'T WHAT I DON'T
WANT TO DO IS PUT THE THE BUREAU
IN JEOPARDY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'M A
STUDENT CENTERED ADMINISTRATOR
NOT BEEN THAT MY WHOLE LIFE AND
SO BEST BELIEVE IF THERE'S WAYS
AND ACTIONS I CAN TAKE.
THAT CAN PROACTIVELY ALLOW ME TO
DO THAT I WILL CERTAINLY DO
ABSOLUTELY BUT IF YOU'RE AWARE
OF THAT AND ANY BAD ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC SO WE'RE OF
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
OR ARIZONA IT'S A PART OF THE
PUBLIC RECORD MY FRIEND AND I
THINK THAT TO TO PUT SOME
LIMITATION ON YOUR ABILITY. TO
SHARE ITEMS OF A PART OF THE
PUBLIC RECORD WITH OUR STUDENTS
OR PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS.
I THINK IS IS SHORT CHANGING
YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES BUT TAKE A
LOOK AT IT WOULD ABSOLUTE THINK
OF SUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER CENTER
TO LETTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CHIEF WHEN
YOU YET STATED EARLIER WHEN YOU
CAME ON ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
YOU HAD.
WAS THE NUMBER OF INVESTIGATORS
YOU HAD AND AND YOU SHOULD THOSE
ABOUT.
THIRTEEN ARE YOU SEEKING TO GET
ANOTHER FIVE SIX SEVEN AND THEN
YOU ALSO MENTIONED SPECIALTY
TRAINING.
IS GOING TO TAKE AWHILE TO TRAIN
THIS FIVE OR SEVEN OR WOULD YOU
MOVE THE THIRTEEN INTO A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY OR HANDFUL
INTO A DIFFERENT CATEGORY AND
TRAIN.
AND TRAIN THE OTHER ONES COME IN
AND HOW WOULD YOU HANDLE THAT
RIGHT SO BASED ON SOME OF THE
INPUT THAT WE GET FROM THE TASK
FORCE THE GOAL WOULD BE ABLE TO
ADJUST TO WHATEVER THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE.
AND I WOULD DEFINITELY WANT TO
KEEP THEM IN THERE AND JUST GET
THEM TRAINED UP ABSOLUTELY. TO
USE YOURS YOUR MORE SENIOR
INVESTIGATORS TO FOR ADDITIONAL
TRAINING AND THEN WHEN WE BRING
IN THE ADDITIONAL SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR TO WIN.
ONE HOPEFULLY THEY AND AND WHAT
ARE YOU DOING RIGHT NOW TO
RECRUIT --
FOR THESE INVESTIGATORS THAT YOU
NEED JOBS ARE POSTED RIGHT NOW.
AND THE OCEAN YES SIR AND WE
ACTUALLY HAD A INNER WE HAD
INTERVIEWS LAST WEEK AND WHAT IS
YOUR BUDGET AND YOUR BUDGET AND
ALL --
ANOTHER FIVE ANOTHER TEN WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR GREAT QUESTION WITH THE
RESTRUCTURE I THINK WE WILL BE --
BUT I AM NOT OPPOSED TO GETTING
ADDITIONAL STAFF BECAUSE I THINK
YOU KNOW IT IT DEFINITELY WILL
BE SOMETHING WE NEED TO LOOK AT
AND FOLLOW UP WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU WOULD TAKE. FOR YOU TO FEEL
PRETTY COMFORTABLE THAT YOU HAVE
ENOUGH --
THEY THE NUMBER OF INVESTIGATORS
SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO HANDLE
THE WORKLOAD THAT'S A THAT'S A
HARD UESTION ASKS ME TO ANSWER
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE PART OF ME
WANTS TO SEE HOW THE RE ORG
LOOKS FIRST.
AND THEN ONCE WE GET THESE TWO
POSITIONS IN AN ADDITIONAL STAFF
I THINK I'LL GET A BETTER HAVE A
BETTER IDEA IN REGARDS TO
BUILDING BEFORE I I THINK THAT
ALSO NEED TO BE A TOP PRIORITY.
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO DO THE WE NEED TO KNOW
THAT --
BECAUSE THE GORE AGAIN I KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THE STUDENTS --
WHO THE --
UNDERSERVED THOSE VETERANS AND
EVERYONE ELSE THAT ARE LOOKING
FOR THAT FIRST JOB TO GET OUT OF
SCHOOL START WORKING.
AND IF THERE'S A ISSUES OUT
THERE THAT WE SHOULD CONCERN
OURSELVES THAT JUST WITH OUR
STUDENTS BUT IF YOU HAVE THE
ACCESS AND TODAY IN THE INTERNET
TO JUST.
SEND IN AN EMAIL --
OUT TO THE VARIOUS --
STUDENTS ABOUT OTHER SCHOOLS
OTHER STATES AND YOU NEED TO
BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND SO --
AT LEAST FOR IDENTIFICATION OF A
SCHOOL THAT HAS POOR HISTORY
VERSES ONE THAT HAS GOOD HISTORY
WHETHER BE IN OR OUT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA.
GERMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME WE APPRECIATE IT I
THINK WE GAVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF HOMEWORK TO COME BACK WITH
SOME LEGISLATIVE IDEAS THAT WE
COULD HELP MAKE YOUR JOB EASIER
A BENEFIT THE STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME STAY
WITH MISTER.
GOT OVER IT OKAY VERY GOOD.
SO WE'RE NOT GONNA TALK A LITTLE
ABOUT SCHOOL CLOSURES AND IF
STUDENTS ARE BEING WELL SERVED --
MISTER SCOTT THEY'LL VERDE
PLEASE COME ON UP.
YOU ARE THE OFFICE YOU'RE THE
CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF STUDENT
ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF WELCOME.
EACH.
YES IT'S A LITTLE SQUEAKY IT'S
NOT YOU.
HERE I MATTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M I'M
PROUD TO BE IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT --
THE OFFICES STUDENTS DISTANCE
AND RELEASE EFFORTS AND IN
GENERALLY TO BE THE FIRST --
CHIEF OF THE OF THIS PARTICULAR
OFFICE --
LIKE DR MARIANNE I AND SLOWLY
CREEPING UP ON ABOUT TWO ASIAN --
WORKING IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES IN
VARIOUS SECTORS INCLUDING.
ON TEN YEARS IN THE QUEUE
COMMUNICABLE JUST CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE BEFORE I CAME OVER TO
TAKE OVER AS THE CHIEF OF OCR.
I'M AND I'M VERY STUDENT CENTRIC
AS DOCTOR MERION MENTION AS WELL.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT REALLY
DREW ME TO THIS POSITION WAS --
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
STUDENT PROTECTION --
AND TO HELP STUDENTS IN A VERY
DIRECT AND HOPEFULLY MEANINGFUL
WAY -- SO
TODAY I'M GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THREE AREAS --
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL HELP US
SPEAK TO THE QUESTION THIS POST
ON THE AGENDA ITEM TODAY.
THE HISTORY OF SO OUR BRIEF AS
IT IS -- BUT
BUT EVENTFUL I THINK.
HELLO SO ARE IN THE BUREAU DO
PUT STUDENTS FIRST AND VALUE
STUDENT PROTECTION IN ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS.
AND HOW WE ACTIVATE AND DEPLOY
QUICKLY --
WHEN SCHOOLS UNFORTUNATELY CLOSE --
AN ONGOING TOPIC OF TODAY'S
DISCUSSION.
SO --
STARTING WITH THE HISTORY DURING
THE BUREAU'S TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SUNSET REVIEW.
VARIOUS CHANGES WERE MADE TO THE
TERRACE PRACTICE ACT TO IMPROVE
ITS EFFECTIVENESS AND STRENGTHEN
ITS STUDENT SUPPORT CAPABILITIES.
SENATE BILL --
ELEVEN NINETY TWO CREATED --
SAR.
AND THE OFFICE OF STUDENT
ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF BEGAN
OPERATING ON JULY ONE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN UNDER MY
LEADERSHIP --
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY TWO
ALSO CREATED THE STUDENT TUITION
RECOVERY FUND SOMETHING THAT
DEBBIE --
OUTLINE VERY.
EARLY AND CORRECTLY.
ALSO KNOWN AS STRYFE I'M SORRY
PROBABLY BELIEVE USING ACRONYMS
BOTH OF US ARE IN STRESS
THROUGHOUT MY TESTIMONY.
THAT MEANS.
THE STRIP FUND ALLOW STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT THE TIME OF SCHOOL
CLOSURE OR WHO WERE ENROLLED IN
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS OF
THE SCHOOL'S CLOSURE. TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT FOR
ANY FUNDS THEY PAY THE SCHOOL --
THROUGH THE STRESS FUND.
THOSE ARE SOME KEY HISTORICAL
ITEMS -- OUR
DUTIES ARE TO CONDUCT OUTREACH
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT --
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS AFFECTED
BY PIPE PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS.
UNLAWFUL ACTIVITIES OR ON IN THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO CLOSURE.
AND ALSO TO SERVE AS THE PRIMARY
PER TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF POST
SECONDARY STUDENTS BOTH CURRENT
AND PROSPECTIVE PASSED STUDENTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
WORKING IN CONSULTATION WITH
OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL.
AGENCIES SOME OF WHICH ARE
CALLED OUT SPECIFICALLY IN THE
ENABLING STATUTE SUCH AS CALVET
WHICH HAS BEEN MENTIONED
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND OTHER CELLS ARE
ALL --
DIRECT PARTNERS.
SO MOVING ON TO THAT STUDENT
FIRST APPROACH --
STAR COUNSEL STUDENTS AS THEY
NAVIGATE THEIR FINANCIAL AND
ACADEMIC FUTURES.
THOSE ARE ALSO PROVIDE SCHOOL
CLOSURE ON PROVIDE SCHOOL
CLOSURE SCHOOL CLOSURE SORRY
WORKSHOPS --
WE ASSIST STUDENTS IN SEEKING A
REFUND FROM THE SCHOOL IF
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO THAT.
WE ADVISE STUDENTS HOW TO
REQUEST THAT THEIR STUDENT LOANS
BE DISCHARGED THROUGH THE
FEDERAL.
LOAN JUST CHARGE PROGRAMS OF
WHICH THERE ARE SEVERAL AND
OFTEN DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE.
WE GUIDE STUDENTS REQUESTING
REIMBURSEMENT FOR ANY OUT OF
POCKET PAYMENTS TO THE SCHOOL
THROUGH THE STRESS.
IN ITSELF CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
COMPLICATED WE'VE HOPEFULLY
WE'VE MADE THAT.
EASIER TO UNDERSTAND THROUGH
SOME EFFORTS --
SINCE OF SARS COME ONLINE.
AND WE PROVIDE INFORMATION TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE INTERESTING
INTERESTED IN TRANSFERRING TO
ANOTHER INSTITUTION.
OR TO TAKE PART IN A TEACH OUT
AGREEMENT IF THERE IS ONE IN
PLACE WHEN THE SCHOOL CLOSES --
WE WORK WITH STATE AND PRIVATE
ENTITIES.
WE CONDUCT ENFORCEMENT RELATED
RESEARCH PASSENGER GLAZER
MENTIONED --
WE DEVELOP A SOCIAL MEDIA PER --
WHICH HAS BEEN A VERY KEY.
COMPONENT OF SARS AFFECTED
MISSING COMMUNICATING WITH
STUDENTS --
WEB CONTENT AS WELL WE'VE GOT
OUR OWN WEBSITE WITH A LOT OF
INFORMATION FOR STUDENTS THAT WE
ARE CONTINUALLY EVALUATING
EXPANDING.
ALL OF WHICH ARE THERE TO HELP
EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO INFORM AND
SERVE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS --
STAR HAS FAILED --
SO CLOSE SCHOOL EVENTS --
IN THE FORM BOTH OF IN PERSON
WORKSHOPS ALSO A REMOTELY --
AS WELL THROUGH --
CONFERENCE CALLS --
EMAIL COMMUNICATION AND ONE ON
ONE MEETINGS.
AND ON ON THE HORIZON HOPEFULLY
OUR IN OUR NEXT THING WE'RE
LOOKING INTO IS THE BILL YOUR
PRIDE OUT REACH REMOTELY --
THROUGH WEB IN OUR PLATFORM --
WE HAVE SUCCEEDED TO DATE AND
GRANT AND HELPING THE BUREAU
GRANT MORE THAN TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN FINANCIAL
RELIEF. TO STUDENTS AFFECTED BY --
CLOSURES OR WHO OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE. FOR STRYFE
REIMBURSEMENT.
I WOULD SAY OUR BIGGEST JOB MOST
IMPORTANT WORK --
WE DO A LOT OF THINGS --
BUTIS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS REACHING OUT TO STUDENTS AND
WORKING WITH THEM --
WHEN SCHOOLS UNFORTUNATELY
CLOSER OPERATION OFTEN AS YOU'LL
HEAR A LEADER IN MY TESTIMONY
WITH VERY SHORT NOTICE --
IT'S CERTAINLY ARE MOST RESOURCE
INTENSIVE --
COMPONENTS IN ON IT IF NOT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT --
IN STANDING UP THE PROGRAM IN
AND OFFICE I'VE HIRED STAFF
WHOSE DUTIES INCLUDE.
FACILITATING CLOSE SCHOOL OUT
REACH ADVANCE.
DEVELOPING AND MAINTAINING A
STUDENT FOCUSED WEBSITE --
BUILDING AND MAINTAINING CLOSE
WILL CONTENT FOR THAT WEBSITE
WHICH IS EXPANDING GREATLY HAS
EXPANDED GREATLY --
DEVELOPING AND UPDATING OUTREACH
MATERIALS RECENTLY TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON TO ADDRESS SOME OF
SENATOR GLAZERS CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW WE COMMUNICATE --
RED FLAGS ENFORCEMENT RELATED
INFORMATION.
UPDATING THE CLOSE SCHOOL
PROCESS AND PACKET EVERYTHING
THAT THE BUREAU DID PRIO SORRY
AROUND CLOSE SCHOOLS HAS BEEN.
RE EVALUATED REASSESS --
UPDATED --
WITH THAT WITH THE I. ON
IMPROVEMENT FOR STUDENTS.
I INCLUDING CREATING NEW
PROCEDURES.
A STAFF ALSO COORDINATES THE
LOGISTICS OF THESE EVENTS OFTEN
WITH VERY SHORT NOTICE --
TO TRY TO PUT ON THE BEST
POSSIBLE SET OF INFORMATION WE
CAN FOR STUDENTS INCLUDING.
INVITING CAM --
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT I'M SORRY
THE STATE APPROVING AUTHORITY
FOR VETERANS EDUCATION TO THE
CAL THAT --
OFTEN THESE SCHOOLS HAVE ON
VARIOUS FUNDING SOURCES LIKE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID --
TITLE --
THIRTY EIGHT IN GI BILL --
WORKERS --
WORKERS COMP AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT SO --
IF THOSE ARE IF IF SCHOOLS TO
CLOSE HAVE FUNDING TO THOSE
SOURCES WE COORDINATE WITH THOSE
ENTITIES. TO TRY TO GET THEM ON
SITE WITH US DURING THE
WORKSHOPS AND IF NOT AT LEAST
GET THEIR INFORMATION IN THE
HANDS OF STUDENTS EFFECTIVELY.
THROUGH OUR CLOSE SCHOOL OUR
EACH EFFORTS WE'VE SUCCESSIVELY
ADVANCED AND BEGAN SUBMITTED TO
THE BUREAU FOR APPROVAL TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY STRYFE
CLAIMS --
AND AGAIN IT TOTALS AT TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR NUMBER THAT
I X. I QUOTED EARLIER.
WE'VE WORKED TO IMPLEMENT A CASE
MANAGEMENT STYLE APPROACH TO
WORKING WITH THE STUDENTS AGAIN
AYE AYE IN MY PERSONAL OPINION.
A REALLY STRONG IMPROVEMENT OF
THE OUTREACH EFFORTS POST OF
STAR VERSES THE BUREAU'S PRIO
SAR --
EFFORTS --
WERE WE REALLY EMPHASIZE
CUSTOMER SERVICE --
AND PRIORITIES PRIORITIZE --
IDENTIFYING WHAT IS THE MAXIMUM
POSSIBLE REALLY UNDER THE BOTH
THE CURRENT FEDERAL AND STATE
STATUTES AND REGULATIONS.
AGAIN BEING INFORMED OF EXACTLY
WERE OUT WITH CLOSE SCHOOL
DISCHARGES BARS DEFENSE TO
REPAYMENT OTHER TYPES OF
DISCHARGES.
THE AWARD OF THIRD PARTY
EDUCATIONAL CREDITS AS DEBBIE
MENTIONED --
STRYFE -- AS
AS THOSE RULES HAVE CHANGED AS
WELL SO.
WE REALLY TRY TO GET EVERYTHING
WE POSSIBLY CAN FOR THE STUDENT
AND DO WHAT WE CAN FOR THE
STUDENT.
THIS APPROACH CREATES A
CONNECTION WITH STUDENTS EARLY
ON THE PROCESS HELPS BUILD A
REPORT AND TRUSTS.
AND GOES ALL THE WAY THROUGH
WRAPAROUND SERVICES WHICH
INCLUDES --
WORKING WITH A STUDENT POST
CLOSURE OF AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'VE.
FALLEN ON THE PHONE YEAH I'M
TAKING THE RIGHT STEPS ON THEIR
FEET --
TRANSFERRED IF THEIR INTENT WAS
TO TRANSFER.
GET THE FUNDS BACK IF THAT WAS
THEIR INTENT --
WHATEVER IT IS.
WE WORK WITH THEM IN THAT CASE
MANAGEMENT APPROACH.
OKAY THE NEXT ITEM THE LAST ITEM
IS CLOSE SCHOOL --
WHEN I CALLED EARLIER ACTIVATION
OR DEPLOYMENT?
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
SCHOOL POLLUTION CLOSURES THAT
HAVE BOTH COME OUT THIS MORNING
THIS AFTERNOON --
BRIGHT WOULD IN ARGOSY I FEEL
LIKE THOSE ACTIVE IN OUR STUDENT
OUTREACH APPROACH --
WHEN WE RECEIVE NOTICE OF BRIGHT
WHICH CLOSURE UNFORTUNATELY ONLY
FORTY EIGHT HOURS BEFORE THE
ACTUAL --
CLOSURE ITSELF FOR THE LOCK THE
DOORS IN DECEMBER --
SORRY MEDIALLY BEGAN WORKING ON
CORD MEANS CLOSE SCHOOL EVENTS
FOR THE STUDENTS AT ALL THE
ELEVEN EFFECTIVE AFFECTED
CAMPUSES THAT DEBBIE MENTIONED.
BPP N. T. C. A. PROACTIVELY
REACH OUT TO LEGISLATORS OFFICES
TO PROVIDE THEM THE NOTICE OF
THE IMPENDING CLOSURE.
AND SHARE AVAILABLE RESOURCES
FOR EFFECTIVE STUDENT AFFECTED
STUDENTS IN THAT CASE WE'RE
TALKING --
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED STUDENTS WHO ARE
IMPACTED.
WITHIN A WEEK OF THE CLOSURE WE
HAD HELD ELEVEN IN PERSON CLOSE
SCHOOL WORKSHOPS.
AND HAVE AN HAD CONNECTED WITH
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY STUDENTS
IN PERSON AND ON THOSE WORKSHOPS.
AND TO DATE OF PROCESS TWO
HUNDRED FORTY TO STRIP CLAIMS AS
A RESULT.
SINCE THEN WE ALSO CONDUCTED TO
ADDITIONAL WORKSHOPS IN THE SAN
DIEGO AREA. ONE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNICANTS
DISTRICT AND THEN ANOTHER
STANDALONE WORKSHOP THAT WE DID
S. AND THAT WAS THE HARDEST.
AREA HERE WITH THE FOR WITH FOR
CAMPUS CLOSURES --
IN THAT JUNE GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
WITH ARGOSY MOVING ON TO ARGOSY
SIMILARLY.
BE SHORT SHORT TIME FRAME AGAIN
BP RECEIVE NOTICE FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVENTH.
THAT ARGOSY WOULD NO LONGER HAVE
ACCESS.
TO BEFORE BP RECEIVE THAT
OFFICIAL CLOSURE NOTICE --
SO I WAS ALREADY PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO STUDENTS AT
ARGOSY CAMPUSES DISSEMINATING
INFORMATION.
NOW KEEP IN MIND ONE THING THAT
HAS NOT BEEN MENTIONED UP TO
THIS POINT IS LAST YEAR --
OUR INSTITUTE HAD ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY WERE CLOSING SEVERAL OF
THEIR BRANCH CAMPUSES.
SORRY I DON'T REMEMBER THE
NUMBER OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I
BELIEVE IT WAS SEVEN CAMPUSES
THAT THEY CLOSED LAST YEAR --
THAT WERE ON IN THAT ACTIVELY
ENGAGED ON IT ONE OF WHICH WAS
ACTIVELY STILL ENGAGED IN
INTERNAL TEACH OUT.
THE OTHERS HAD CLOSED --
BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST SO --
SAR HAD ALREADY WORKED WITH --
THEIR CORPORATE CONTACTS HAD
GOTTEN STUDENT ROSTERS HAD MADE
CONTACT WITH STUDENTS AND HAD
CONDUCTED WORKSHOPS AS WELL SO
WE ARE KIND OF HAD.
UNLIKE BRIGHT WOULD SORT OF HAD
A HAD A PRE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP IN THAT AREA --
SO AGAIN FOR THE NEW CAMPUS IS
THAT WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THE LOSS OF THEIR
FINANCIAL AID WE IMMEDIATELY GOT
OUT THERE AND START
DISSEMINATING INFORMATION --
AS DOCTOR MERRY MENTION
UNFORTUNATELY WE COULDN'T --
DEFINITIVELY SAY THIS THE FIFTH
OFFICIAL DECISION THEY HAD MADE
THAT BEEN MADE BY THE SCHOOL BUT
AS OFTEN AS THIS CASE WHEN
SCHOOLS LOSE THEIR FINANCIAL AID
THAT CLOSURE IS.
IMMINENT SO WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE
STUDENTS AWARE OF US AWARE OF
OUR SERVICES.
AND AGAIN HELP BUILD THAT REPORT
EARLIER --
THAT I MENTIONED.
THEN ON MARCH FIRST BP ISSUED A
PRESS RELEASE ENCOURAGING.
AGAIN THIS IS SPEAKING TO THE
PROACTIVE NATURE OF WHAT WE DO
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS. TO CONNECT
TO OBTAIN THEIR ACADEMIC AND
FINANCIAL RECORDS.
FROM THE INSTITUTION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
BY.
ACCESSING THE STUDENT PORTAL
GETTING THEIR RECORDS ON IT'S
OFTEN AN ISSUE IN SCHOOLS CLOSE --
IN IN WITH SHORT TIME FRAME
STUDENTS REALLY EITHER ACADEMIC
AND FINANCIAL RECORDS FOR MANY
REASONS.
AND SO -- WE
KIND OF SNIFF THAT OUT AS A
POTENTIAL PROBLEM WITH THIS
SCHOOL AND HAD HAD INFORMATION
TO STUDENTS REALLY AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE --
ENCOURAGING THEM TO GET THOSE
DIRECTOR AS DOCTOR MERION OTHERS
MENTION MARCH FOURTHV. P. N.
ISSUES THEY MERGING EMERGENCY
DECISION.
HALTING THE COLLECTION OF
TUITION AND ANY NEW STUDENT ROLE
MINUTE ARGOSY.
SO THAT'S MARCH FOURTH BY MARCH
THIRTEENTH SO IT'S NINE DAYS
CALENDAR DAYS --
SARHAD BUT AT THAT POINT HAD
ALREADY HELD CLOSE SCHOOL
WORKSHOPS FOR ALL AFFECTED
STUDENTS AT ALL THE CAMPUS IS
THAT A CLOSED.
AS WITH BRIGHT WORD --
WE'RE NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
REASSESSING THE NEED TO CONDUCT
MORE WORKSHOPS.
AGAIN VERY SIMILARLY
UNFORTUNATELY COINCIDENTLY
APPROXIMATELY ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED STUDENTS AFFECTED BY
THIS CLOSURE AS WELL --
SARS CONNECTED WITH
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
STUDENTS SINCE THIS LAST ROUND
OF CLOSURES WITH ART INSTITUTE.
AND PROCESSED ABOUT SIXTY STRIVE
CLAIMS [inaudible]
SORRY.
VERY BRIEFLY IN CLOSING I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION ANOTHER
COMPONENT OF THOSE ARE SERVICES
THAT IS COME UP TODAY AS WELL.
WHICH IS THAT WE ALSO ENGAGE IN
PROACTIVE OUT REACH THROUGH
PARTICIPATION IN EVENTS
ORGANIZED OR SPONSORED BY --
STAR PARTNERS.
EXAMPLES HERE WOULD BE TABLES
AND PRESENTATIONS AT VARIOUS
COLLEGE FAIRS.
ARE CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS IN
THEIR CALIFORNIA TRANSITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
AND WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGE ADMISSION
COUNSELORS.
AMONG OTHERS SO ONE OF THOSE ARE
KEY OBJECTIVES IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IS NOT ONLY TO BUILD ON
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND TO DO
MORE PROACTIVE OUT REACH. FOR
MORE PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS BUT TO
DO SO OUR SELF AS WELL TO CREATE
ORGANIZE AND PROMOTE OUR OWN
OUTREACH EVENTS.
WE HELD ONE SUCH EVENT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND WE PLAN TO
HOLD MORE IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN CLOSER
STRIVES TO PROVIDE STUDENTS THE
INFORMATION AND TOOLS TO MAKE
INFORMED EDUCATED DECISIONS AND
THEIR ACADEMIC FUTURES.
AND TO ENSURE STUDENTS CAN
SUCCEED FALLING BACK WITH MY
ORIGINAL COMMENTS OF MY STRONG
BELIEF AND STUDENT SUCCESS --
SEVERAL CONTINUE TO MAKE
STUDENTS IT'S PRIORITY.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ME I'LL BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER THOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE ARE TWO ANY QUESTIONS
PLEASE PROCEED.
THE THE ABILITY TO TO PARTNER UP
WITH WITH ALL THESE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES IS SO VERY IMPORTANT
AND AND SOUND LIKE IT'S A VITAL --
DO THE SCHOOLS KNOW THAT THAT
YOU'RE THERE TO SERVE AND HELP --
IN THE PROCESS IF THE CLOSING IS
EVIDENT --
IF THERE IS A I GUESS AN
EVOLUTION OF OF NEGATIVE THAT'S
PLACING THEY COULD REACH OUT FOR
HELP --
RATHER THAN SHUT THE DOOR AND
THAT CAUSES PROBLEMS.
SHARE THAT WITH ME YEAH WE'RE
DEFINITELY TRYING TO EXPAND THE
SPOKE US A SCOPE OF OUR
AWARENESS YOU KNOW --
AGAIN STILL BEING FAIR IT FAIRLY
NEW ONLY COME INTO EFFECT ON
JULY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY NOT HAVING A
SPECIFIC --
DISCAL PRE ENROLLMENT DISCLOSURE
MANDATE --
FOR SAR --
WE'RE REALLY TAKING AND AND TO
BE HAVE A VERY ACTIVE SOCIAL
MEDIA PRESENCE --
WEBSITE --
REACHING OUT TO STUDENTS
DIRECTLY THROUGH VARIOUS
CHANNELS AND IT THROUGH OUR
PARTNERS THAT YOU MENTIONED --
THROUGH OUR ADVISORY COMMITTEE
HAVE DONE SEVERAL PRESENTATIONS --
AS MANY AS MUCH AS I CAN TO GET
THE WORD OUT YOU KNOW THAT WE'VE
DON THAT WE'RE HERE THAT WE'RE
HERE TO HELP STUDENTS.
THEY WERE COMMITTED TO HELP
STUDENTS THAT WERE RESOURCE --
THAT'S WHAT I'M I'M STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF EFFORT NEED YOU WE'VE
DEVELOPED A LOT OF COLLATERAL
MATERIALS AS WELL KIND OF DONE
IT THE OLD FASHIONED WAY YOU
KNOW BOOTS ON THE GROUND. ONE OF
MY HOPES WOULD BE AND AND I'VE
MENTIONED THIS PREVIOUSLY A SORT
OF A LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL WOULD
BE.
TO IN FACT HAVE A REQUIRE PRE
ENROLLMENT DISCLOSURE --
FOR SAR SO THAT THE NOT ONLY
SCHOOLS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
KNOW ABOUT US BUT THEY BE
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE THAT
INFORMATION TO STUDENTS PRE
ENROLLMENT AND ALSO MANAGER.
IT WOULD THERE BE AN AUDITING
PROCESS TO TO SEE THE WARNING
SIGNS.
THAT YOU NEED TO STEP IN AND SAY
HEY THIS MAY HAPPEN.
LET'S START WORKING TOGETHER.
I THINK I REMEMBER THE FUTURE AT
THE END THAT AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE FUTURE OF THE STUDENTS.
OUR DIRECT --
YEAH THE I THINK THAT WOULD BE I
ANY ANY STRING THING WE CAN DO
IN THAT AREA WOULD BE WELCOMED
WE CERTAINLY ARE.
WE BEING MYSELF IS IS DIRECTLY
INVOLVED WITH ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS AND MEETINGS WITH
THE OTHER BUREAU CHIEF
SPECIFICALLY.
AROUND ENFORCEMENT AND
DISCIPLINE --
WHEN THEY'RE I WAS AWARE OF --
THEY DEFINITELY COME ON TO SARS
RADAR WE BEGIN RESEARCHING OTHER
COMPARABLE SCHOOLS AND PROGRAMS
IN THE AREA IF WE FEEL LIKE --
THAT RED RED FLAG IS POTENTIALLY
HEADING TOWARDS CLOSURE --
SO -- BUT
JUST IN GENERAL YOU KNOW SOMEONE
EARLIER MENTIONED THAT.
STRICT ELIGIBILITY HAS BEEN
EXPANDED TO PROGRAM JUST
CONTINUATIONS AS WELL SO IF AN
INSTITUTION FOR EXAMPLE --
STOPS OFFERING A PARTICULAR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING DEGREE
PROGRAM --
BUT BUT CONTINUES TO STAY OPEN
AS AN INSTITUTION --
OR HAS THAT THE APPROVAL OR
THIRTY TO OFFER THAT PROGRAM
TAKEN AWAY BY ANOTHER PARTY --
THEN WE ARE INVOLVED IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE
AS WELL GET IN GET THOSE ROSTERS
TALK TO STUDENTS ABOUT.
TRANSFER OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL
AN AREA BUT AND LIKE I SAID I
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU ANY
STRENGTHENING WE CAN DO AT AND
IN TERMS OF EARLY.
WARNING I I WOULD IT ONLY HELPS
MY JOBS.
I AND I WOULD THINK ANY PUNITIVE
ACTION --
CAN BE PREVENTED WITH
COMMUNICATIONS BECAUSE ANYONE
WHO'S TO ADMINISTERS THE SCHOOLS
AND AND MAYBE LOOKS TO EXPAND OR
WHATEVER AND IF THEY HAVE A
HISTORY OF NEGATIVITY.
WITH THE BUREAU YOURSELF.
BACK IN -- I
WOULD HOPE STOP THEM FROM
EXPANDING.
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S IT'LL VITAL
TO COMMUNICATE WITH YOU I AGREE.
THANK YOU MA'AM SHOULD CONSIDER
ARCHULETA YOUR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MISTER ABOUT THEIR DAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I I
SO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORKS.
OF YOUR OFFICE THANK YOU ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU'VE --
REVIEWED WITH US ARE SO
IMPORTANT --
THAT A LOT OF THEM ARE --
IN REACTION TO BAD THINGS
HAPPENING BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE
YOUR EMPHASIS ON PRODUCTIVITY I
CERTAINLY WANT TO COMMEND
SENATOR HILL WHO AUTHORED THE
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED YOUR
OFFICE --
FOR THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT YOU
DO HACER.
NOW WE'RE CURRENTLY ALLOCATED
TEN PERMANENT POSITIONS AND WE
HAVE SEVEN OF THOSE TEN
POSITIONS FILLED CURRENTLY AND
ARE ACTIVELY LOOKING.
TO FILL THOSE THREE VACANT
POSITIONS AND WIRE THOSE THREE
VACANT POSITIONS THERE.
WE HAD TWO OF THEM WERE FILLED
AND YOU KNOW WE HAD BOTH MOVE ON
FOR ONE IS A PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITY ONE IT WAS A A LIFE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE'RE WE'RE LIKE
I SAID WE'RE WE'RE ACTIVELY
TRYING TO REFILL THOSE NOW.
GREAT THANK YOU SO I WANT.
TO TOUCH THREE AREAS OF
QUESTIONS THE FIRST ONE WAS --
IN TERMS OF YOUR PROACTIVE WORK
AND YOU EMPHASIZE THAT IN YOUR
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU DO TO GET
OUT IN FRONT OF STUDENTS ARE
POTENTIAL STUDENTS.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT --
THAT YOU DO --
CONDUCT INDUSTRY IN ENFORCEMENT
RELATED RESEARCH YET FOR SPENT
RELATED RESEARCH WE DO AND THAT
THAT INFORMATION CAN BE PROVIDED
TO PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS AT
COLLEGE FAIRS AND WORKSHOPS
CORRECT I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
QUESTION THAT I ASKED THAT.
THE BUREAU CHIEF OF A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
WHICH IS THAT HOW WHAT WORK DO
YOU UNDERTAKE TO BE AWARE OF
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES THAT
OCCUR IN OTHER STATES.
IN OTHER IN OTHER STATES CORRECT
SOFT ITHACA COLLEGE THE NATIONAL
COLLEGE IT IS HAD.
ENFORCEMENT ACTION TAKEN AGAINST
THEM AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD COME TO YOUR ATTENTION --
POSSIBLE POSSIBLY YOU KNOW IF IT
I THINK IF IT CAME ON THE ON THE
RADAR OF THE JURORS ENFORCEMENT.
UNIT THEN I WOULD DEFINITELY BE
AWARE OF IT AS WELL BECAUSE I'M
INVOLVED IN ALL THOSE --
MEETINGS --
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS IN OUR FOR
JUSTICE I'M SORRY SHOULD MENTION
THIS EARLIER KIND OF THE
MECHANISM OF HOW THAT
INFORMATION IS SHARED WITH
STUDENTS?
IN OUR OUT REACHED EVENTS IS IS
INFORMED BY THAT IT RESEARCH
THAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT IS
REFERENCED IN THE STATUTE AS
WELL. ONE OF THE EFFORTS WE DID
IS WE WENT BACK WE BEING --
STAR STAFF WENT BACK AND TOOK A
PRETTY DEEP DIVE INTO --
THE NATURE OF THE MOST COMMON
COMPLAINTS THAT THE BUREAU HAS
RECEIVED OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
AND EVALUATE ALL THESE CLOSE ALL
THOSE CLUSTERED THEM LOOK AT
THEM CLOSELY AND THEN USE THEM
TO BOTH VALIDATE SOME OF OUR
TALKING POINTS AROUND RED FLAGS.
AND ADD TO THEM AS WELL SO THAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT SORT OF
GENERAL MESSAGING RIGHT THAT NE
OF THE THINGS TO LOOK OUT FOR
WOULD BE.
X. Y. Z. MISREPRESENTATION
POLLUTION RATES OR ORAL OR LACK
OF DISCLOSURE OR OTHER TYPES OF
RED FLAGS --
A RUSH TO SIGN IN ROMAN
DOCUMENTS --
NOT ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS --
WE HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF THEM
THAT'S IN OUR THAT'S OUR SORT OF
STOCK TALKING POINTS MANY OF
THOSE LIKE I SAID WERE VALIDATED
BY.
OR ADDED TO OUR TALK LIST OF
TALKING POINTS BASED ON REAL
CASES THAT THE BUREAU HAS SEEN
OVER TIME AS WELL.
THIS TRIED TO TRY TO MAKE
STUDENTS INFORMED AND AWARE WHEN
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS THAT THEY'RE
KEEPING THEIR EYE OUT FOR THOSE
THINGS IN ITS IN ITS AGAIN IT'S
BASED ON A REALITY IN THE SENSE
OF THOSE ARE ACTUAL COMPLAINTS
THAT OTHER STUDENTS HAVE HAD AND
SIMILAR SCHOOLS.
NOW AS IT RELATES --
TO SCHOOLS OUT OF STATE I THINK
THE ONLY CONNECTION POINTS I CAN
REALLY THINK OF OUR THE OTHER
THING THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
TALKING POINTS ARE --
ITS RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
REVIEWING ACCREDITATION STATUS
OF SCHOOLS --
IF THERE'S ANY THIRD PARTY --
APPROVED FOR OF THE PROGRAM --
TOOLS AND TIPS AND RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO RESEARCH THOSE. TO
SOME OF YOUR PREVIOUS COMMENTS
AS WELL ABOUT INFORMATION BEING
PUBLIC SO --
WE HAVE WE HAVE TALKING POINTS
ABOUT ANY --
PUBLICLY AWARE AVAILABLE IN
MINISTRY OF ACTIONS AGAINST THE
SCHOOL --
PREVIOUSLY THAT SOMETHING THAT
WE ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO TAKE A
LOOK AT MUCH OF WHICH IS ON THE
BUREAU SITE UNDER THE DISCIPLINE
PAGE BUT BUT IN IN IN YOUR
EXAMPLE YES THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY TAKE THEM.
OUTSIDE OF STATE AS WELL --
I CAN THINK OF ONE I CAN ONLY DO
ONE PERSONAL EXAMPLE OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD IN THE MOMENT BUT I
IT ONE OF THE CAL TAP THE VINCE --
THE THE THE WITH QUE VETERANS
LOOKING AT USING THEIR G. I.
pWITH THE STUDENT THAT WAS
LOOKING AT A SCHOOL IN IOWA.
AND ABOUT THEIR ACCREDITATION IN
THEIR PROFESSIONAL ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS IN THEIR PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION THAT OVERSAW THAT
PROGRAM.
AND THE DISCUSSION IN REAL TIME
JUST TIONS WHERE THEY WERE OTHER
STATES AND SO I AGREE WITH YOU I
I FALL I I FIND THAT TO BE UNDER
THE STARR'S PURVIEW BECAUSE IT
DOES TALK ABOUT PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS AND PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS.
ARE OFTEN NOT ONLY WAYNE PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTION IN
CALIFORNIA VERSUS ANOTHER BUT
OFTEN PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
INSTITUTION VERSUS PUBLIC
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTION OR IN
STATE VERSUS OUT OF STATE.
SO S. I I I I AGREE WITH YOU WE
JUST HAVEN'T HAD A TON OF
EXAMPLES OF OF OF THE OUT OF
STATE COMPONENT.
IS A LOT A LOT THANK YOU FOR
THAT A LOT OF THE A LOT OF THESE
NATIONAL SCHOOLS THEY THEY THEY
ADVERTISED TO GET CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS TO ENROLL IS THAT WOULD
THAT BE FAIR TO SAY.
YES AND HE A ARE YOU IN A
POSITION TO SEE THE CLAIMS THEY
MAKE IN THAT ADVERTISEMENTS
THOSE EVER I HAVE SEEN THOSE YES.
AND ARE YOU ABLE TO GO OUT AND
VERIFY WHETHER THEY'RE TRUE OR
THEY'RE NOT.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT WITHIN OUR
SCOPE BUT AGAIN WE DO A I
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS AGAIN AND ARE
TALKING POINTS TO LOOK AT IF
THERE IF THEY ARE --
EITHER FORMALLY OR OUT OFTEN IS
IN NOT IT'S ON THEIR WEBSITE
SOMETIMES IT MIGHT JUST BE
INFORMATION THAT THEY'VE GOTTEN
IN COMMUNICATION WITH AN
ADMISSIONS COUNSELOR --
WE TALK A LOT IN OUR WORKSHOPS
ABOUT PREDATORY ADMISSIONS AND
THAT WOULD BE ONE COMPONENT OF
THAT.
THAT OFTEN TAKES US TO A
DISCUSSION WHERE THEY ARE.
LOOKING AT THAT OTHER STATE OR
IF IT'S A WITHIN CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW THERE ARE THERE ARE ACTUAL
TRACK RECORD OF PLACING STUDENTS
AND EARNING THE WAGES OF THEIR
IT'S IT'S NOT IT'S NOT PERFECT
AND YOU KNOW I I I AGREE TO
ANYTHING WE CAN STRENGTHEN IN
THAT AREA I WOULD.
I WOULD BE SUPPORT OF US BUT WE
ARE ANY PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION.
RIGHT WELL I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I THINK IT
IS WITHIN THE YEARS AGO THAT I
AND YOUR RESPONSIBILITY --
SO YOU YOU --
YOU MENTION THAT A LOT OF THIS
INFORMATION IS SHARED THROUGH
WORKSHOPS YOU HAVE ALL THAT ON
YOUR WEB PAGES IT EASILY
ACCESSIBLE AND TO ANY
PROSPECTIVE STUDENT.
WE DO YES YEAH WE HAVE THE
WORKSHOPS WERE WORKSHOPS
SCHEDULE THERE WE HAVE A
RESEARCHING COLLEGES --
BROCHURE WITH SOME TIPS WE HAVE
WHAT ABOUT THE WORRISOME ISSUES
THAT THE CLUSTER OF COMPLAINTS
AND HOW YOU.
ADDRESS THOSE IN YOU SHARED
INFORMATION WITH PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS ABOUT BEING RUSHED JOHN
TRACTOR.
THEIR VACATION ABOUT EMPLOYMENT
YEAH I DO I DON'T BELIEVE.
I DON'T WANNA SPEAK OUT OF TURN
I'M NOT POSITIVE WHETHER OUR
MOST UPDATED VERSION OF THE
POWER POINT THAT WE USE WHEN
WE'RE OUT DOING THE PRESENTATION
THAT HAS ALL THOSE TALKING
POINTS.
IS CURRENTLY UP LOADED BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY --
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS WE
DEFINITELY PROVIDED TO THEM WHEN
WE'RE ON SITE WE DEFINITELY GIVE
THEM THE WORK THOUGH THAT'S WHAT
I'M FLYING.
YEAH I I APPRECIATE HOW WHAT ONE
ON ONE IS THE BEST YOU'RE APT.
BUT GREED IS THAT HAVE REALLY
MOST KIDS HOW MANY HOW WHAT'S
THE ENROLLMENT NUMBERS AND THEN
HOW MANY OF YOU TOUCHING YEAH SO
I HEAR YOU SEEMS LIKE IF YOU IT
AND YOU TALK ABOUT THIS ABOUT
YOU YOU UTILIZING.
YOUR WEB PAGE AND TRADITIONAL
MEDIANS ET TALK ABOUT THIS IN
YOUR REPORT THE LEGISLATURE BUT
IF YOU'RE NOT REALLY UTILIZING
IT TOO NO WE THIS ALL YEAH.
NO I WAS JUST SPEAKING ABOUT
THAT SPECIFIC POWER POINT WITH
THOSE SPECIFIC DATA FROM THE
RESEARCH THAT WE SEARCH WE DID
FOR SURE THAT THE GENERAL
TALKING POINTS THE RED FLAGS THE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS --
LINKS TO A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE IN THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS A RESOURCE
ARE ALL THERE.
AND AND I I HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP IT IS UPDATED WE
CAN WEAR LITTLE UNDER RESOURCE
THING.
KINDA GET KIND OF IN A STRETCH
RIGHT NOW WITH THE CLOSURES TO
KEEP EVERYTHING UPDATED BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY WITHIN I I TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT'S ON THE
WEBSITE CURRENTLY.
ON ENCOURAGING TO BE MORE ROBUST
THAT'S ALL AND WHAT YOU PROVIDE
RESHAPE THAT THE COUPLE OTHER IS
QUICKLY.
WE'VE WITH YOU'VE RAISED THE
ISSUE ABOUT SHORT NOTICE ON
CLOSURES.
PREVIOUS --
WITNESSES OF RACE THAT THE
CONCERNED ABOUT SHORT NOTICES --
YOU MADE REFERENCE TO AT SOME OF
THAT OCCURS BECAUSE OF THE LOSS
OF FINANCIAL AID AT THAT'S THE
FEDERAL HAMMER COMING DOWN.
WHICH MADE QUICKLY FORCES THE BY
THE INSTITUTION SAFE WE'RE NOT
GETTING.
ALRIGHT SO WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT
THAT IF THE IF THE FEDS ARE
MAKING A DECISION ABOUT CUTTING
OFF FINANCIAL AID DO THEY
PROVIDE ANY OF THOSE PRELIMINARY
SIGNALS TO YOU SO YOU CAN
PREPARE FOR A CLOSURE --
NOT NOT NOT TO ME PERSONALLY OR
TO SIR BUT THEY DO MAKE THE
BUREAU AWARE OFTHE VARIOUS
TYPES OF DISCIPLINE STATUS IS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT ISSUES --
INCLUDING HEIGHTENED CASH BEING
ONE OF THE WORST ONES BUT THERE
ARE OTHERS.
EXCUSE ME THEIR OTHER STATUSES
AS WELL THAT THEY TO MAKE THE
BUREAU AWARE OF AND THN THE
ENFORCEMENT --
UNIT IN COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
UNITS --
ATTRACT THOSE IT IS THIS BEFORE
THE FACT YOU'RE AFTER THE FACT
THIS IS BEFORE.
VERY GOOD THAT'S HAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOW FINALLY LET ME
ASK YOU ABOUT THE STUDENT
TUITION RECOVERY FIND.
I HOW HOW MUCH IS CURRENTLY IN
THAT FUD ARTS APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY SIX MILLION TWENTY FIVE
POINT SOMETHING MILLION.
AT OTHER CAPS UNDER LEGISLATION
AS TO WHAT AT A WE ARE AT THOSE
CAP LEVELS WE ARE.
AND IS THAT MAKES SENSE TO YOU
TODAY THAT WERE CAPPING THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S GOING
INTO THIS FIND.
IT DOES -- I
WOULD SAY THAT'S A VERY DYNAMIC
THING IN AND SOMETHING TO REALLY
KEEP OUR EYES ON WITH EACH THREE
LARGE CLOSURES THAT WE JUST HAVE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY HAVE NOT
HAVEN'T --
REALLY --
HIT THAT YET --
I I ANTICIPATE THAT IT WILL
PACKED WHETHER THE CAP IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE TRACKING
CLOSELY --
BECAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE AN
IMPACT ON ON THE INSTITUTIONS --
AND AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ASSESSMENT PROCESS BUT I
THINK WE'RE I THINK WE'RE SOLID
RIGHT NOW.
IT WILL I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
ANY ANY REGULATIONS YOU THINK OR
TOO CONSTRICTING.
THAT WE SHOULD RE EVALUATE GIVEN
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE MARKET
PLACE GETTING GIVEN HOW MANY
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN POTENTIALLY
HURT -- BY
THESE CLOSURES I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD BE OPEN MINDED
TO THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO
BETTER PROTECT THOSE STUDENTS
AND IF WE HAVE A STATUTORY CAP
ON A FIND.
AT THIS GOING TO LIMIT OUR
ABILITY TO BE RESPONSIVE I THINK
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN THAT.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT OUT OF
JAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT'S
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE CLOSER ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED STUDENTS IN EACH SCHOOL
AND I THINK YOU SAID THAT YOU
HAD SOME IN PERSON MEETINGS HAVE --
AND REACH ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE STUDENTS THE MORE
THAN THAT IT WAS CLEAR THAT IT
WAS ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED THAT
ACTUALLY ATTENDED THE OKAY THE
WORKSHOPS THAT THAT TWO HUNDRED
WHATEVER NUMBER IT WAS WAS.
A CLAIMS FILED TO DATE FLETCHER.
SO THE TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS IT
DIDN'T COME IN PERSON DO YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR INFORMATION
TO THE YOU COULD SEND THEM A
LETTER WE DO YEAH WE DO IN THIS
CASE.
QUITE SPEAKING VERY FRANKLY.
AS BAD IN AND IN AND FORTUNATE
AND AND HAS MANY NEGATIVE THINGS
THAT CAME OUT OF THE CA CLOSURES
ONE OF THE GOOD THINGS --
WAS THAT THEY PROVIDED VERY --
THOROUGH A TIMELY ROSTERS --
WELL BEFORE THE CLOSURE AND I
REALLY THING WE NEEDED IN TERMS
OF CONTACT INFORMATION A NON
SCHOOL ISSUE EMAILS PHONE
NUMBERS.
PROGRAM SO WE GOT ALL THAT OF
THE REASON THAT NUMBER SO LARGE
AS WELL -- I
I BELIEVEDEBBIE MENTION OR IT
MAY HAVE BEEN MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT.
WE CONSIDER IN CALCULATING
QUANTIFY IN THAT IMPACTED NUMBER
STUDENTS WHO ARE ENROLLED WITHIN
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS OF
CLOSURE BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY
THIS JEFF ELIGIBILITY WORKS --
SO THERE WASN'T NECESSARILY
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED STUDENTS
ENROLLED ON THE DAY OF THE
CLOSURE BUT AND SO MANY OF THEM --
ARE ARE THOSE WHO'VE COMPLETED
EARLIER A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT TO TRACK DOWN.
BUT WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN WE
WE USE ALL THOSE METHODS OF
COMMUNICATION TO REACH OUT WITH
THEM QUITE FRANKLY SOCIAL MEDIA
OFTEN BEING THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
AGREE GOOD THAT'S WHAT I WAS
HOPING AT THAT YOU WERE DOING.
WHAT RECOURSE IS AVAILABLE FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO SUFFER
ECONOMIC LOSS DUE TO UNLAWFUL
ACTIVITIES MORE CLOSURES OF A
PRIVATE SCHOOL?
YES SO FOR ANYTHING --
THAT THE STUDENT HAS PAID OUT OF
POCKET THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT UNDER THOSE TERMS
YOU MENTIONED TO THE STUDENT
TUITION RECOVERY FUND. FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO TOOK OUT A TITLE
FOR FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID LOANS --
FOR FOR TO PAY FOR THEIR TUITION
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE --
FOR TO HAVE THOSE LOANS
DISCHARGED COOL DISCHARGED
PROGRAM.
AND THEN FOR STUDENTS WHOSE
PROGRAM WAS PAID FOR BY A THIRD
PARTY FOR EXAMPLE --
WE ISN'T AS ONE EXAMPLE THEN WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ISSUE AN
EDUCATIONAL CREDIT TO ANOTHER
INSTITUTION THAT'S ALSO APPROVED
BY WE IF THE STUDENT.
WE OWE A IF THE STUDENT
TRANSFERS TO THAT SCHOOL --
GOOD. FIVE THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS GENTLEMEN WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME YES PLEASE DOCTOR
MARILYN NUMBERS YOU ASKED ABOUT --
COMPLAINTS OVER THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS THREE FIVE HOW
MANY NINETY FIVE THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY FIVE ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU WE HOPE THAT THAT
NUMBER CAN GET REDUCE QUICKLY.
OVER THE YEARS A LONG TIME.
TIME GOES BY.
AND I THINK YOU WHAT YOU
PROBABLY HEARD FROM ALL OF US IS
WE WANT TO BE HELPFUL WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STUDENTS.
ARE EITHER GETTING A GOOD
EDUCATION OR THEY'RE NOT HARMED
BY THE PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION PROCESS.
AGAIN I WILL REINFORCE THAT WE'D
LOVE TO HAVE IDEAS FOR
LEGISLATION WHAT WE DO LET US BE
HELPFUL SO THAT YOU CAN DO YOUR
JOB BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WE APPRECIATE
IT.
AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT
UP -- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S ANYONE
AND FROM THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I THINK THIS MICROPHONE OVER
HERE IS PROBABLY ON THANK YOU
VERY WELCOME THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS BOB CHAIRMAN I AM A
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION.
WHICH IS BASED IN NEW YORK I'M A
BORN AND RAISED CALIFORNIA AND
WAS IN THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION
WORKING ON HIGHER EDUCATION
POLICY -- I
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY I THINK IS --
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN --
POORLY TREATED BY BY COLLEGES
AND I THINK YOU'RE GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION OF THINKING
ABOUT HOW CAN WE HELP THE
STUDENTS WHO WERE HARMED AND HOW
WE CAN PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE --
SENATOR LABOR YOU ASKED ABOUT --
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE COMMON
ELEMENTS OF SOME OF THESE
CLOSURES AND I WANTED TO PROVIDE --
ONE ONE ANSWER TO THAT WHICH
MIGHT BE A SIGNAL. FOR SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
AROUND PREVENTION --
THE CALAMITOUS CLOSURES WHERE
THEIR SUDDEN AND LOTS AND LOTS
OF STUDENTS TEND TO HAVE A
COUPLE OF ELEMENTS TO THEM ONE
IS THAT THEY TEND TO BE COLLEGES.
BETTER FOCUSED ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY ON ROLLING PEOPLE
WITH FINANCIAL AID AND THE
REASON THAT HALF OF THE REASON
THEIR THAT HAPPENS IS THAT THEY
ARE AVOIDING ANY INTERACTION
WHERE THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY MAKE
THE VALUE CASE OF THE THE KIND
OF WHAT WHAT WOULD BE A NORMAL.
VALUE CASE FOR THE THE THE VALUE
OF THE DEGREE FOR THE MONEY
INSTEAD THEY'RE SAYING WE'RE
ACCREDITED WERE APPROVED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE'S MONEY
AVAILABLE AND LETTING THE
STUDENT ASSUME THAT.
THE PRICE MUST BE OKAY WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OR ELSE THEY WOULD
NOT ALLOW THEM TO GET THAT MONEY
AND THEY LOAD THEM UP WITH.
THEIR WITH WITH THE PELL GRANT
WITH AND ROLLING IN FOR A
LENGTHY PERIOD STUDENT THINKS
THEY'RE GETTING A QUALITY
EDUCATION AND THEY DON'T REALIZE
TILL THEY TRY TO GET A JOB THAT
THAT IT'S NOT RELATE.
YOU NOT NOT RELATE THAT SERVING
THEM THE OTHER ELEMENT OF IT IS
THAT THOSE INSTITUTIONS I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THIS WHEN DR
MARION TALKED ABOUT THE FIX THAT
TICKET --
AND AND HOW YOU KNOW THIS IN A
LOT OF THESE SITUATIONS THAT'S
NOT GOING TO THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE.
ENOUGH BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE
SITUATIONS ARE WHERE.
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN THE COLLEGE
IS.
HAS A ROLE WHERE THEIR ROLE IS
EXTRACTING MONEY FROM THAT
KNOWLEDGE SO RATHER THAN HAVING
THE AGENTS AND TRUSTEES.
WHO ARE OVERSEEING THE COLLEGE
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF A GIVE
HER SOMEONE WHO IS DONATING
THEIR TIME DONATING MONEY THEY
WANTED TO BE A GREAT COLLEGE
THEY WANT THE OUTCOMES TO BE
WONDERFUL INSTEAD OF?
INSTEAD EVERYBODY WHO'S DRIVING
THAT COLLEGE IS FOCUSED ON HOW
CAN I GET AS MUCH OF IT AT FOR
ME AS I CAN WHETHER ME OR MY
INVESTORS.
THAT I AM --
I AM REPRESENTING AND THAT IS
DRIVING THE ACTIVITIES SO IT
MEANS.
THERE'S A MOMENT IN TIME WHEN A
SCHOOL IS WHEN WHEN THE PEOPLE
INSIDE THE SCHOOL KNOW.
THAT THE SHIP IS GOING DOWN BUT
NOBODY ON THE OUTSIDE KNOWS
ABOUT IT.
THAT IS THE MOMENT WHEN THE WHEN
IT MATTERS THE MOST WHAT THOSE
PEOPLE'S FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
ARE BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED AN ITT
TECH FOR EXAMPLE ALL THE
EXECUTIVES BASICALLY GRABBED
EVERYTHING THEY COULD FOR
THEMSELVES.
AND THE CURRENT AND THE CURRENT
INVEST WHAT WAS GOING ON THERE
WASN'T ANYTHING LEFT FOR THE
STUDENTS ARE FRANKLY EVEN TO
STAY OPEN LONG ENOUGH TO FINISH.
THE SEMESTER SO THAT DYNAMIC
DRIVES THE CALAMITOUS KINDS OF
CLOSURES THANK YOU SO MUCH HAPPY
TO HELP WITH ANYTHING THAT WAS
VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER TANNA
HELL WITH ERIN READING
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF WEST
COAST UNIVERSITY IN AMERICAN
CAREER COLLEGE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY.
AND JUST TO REITERATE
INSTITUTIONAL --
ACCOUNTABILITY INSTANT SUCCESS
ARE CRITICAL TO HAVING A HEALTHY
SECTOR AND SO WE FULLY WANT TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO DOING SO --
AND WORKING WITH THE BUREAU TO
MEET THOSE ENDEAVORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT.
RIGHT THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
HEARING TODAY THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS